la cité de me voir
va j'ai pas j'ai pas les calmes comme
d'hab ça fait des bugs on sait pas
pourquoi déjà on à la cam 2
le raid qui par les amis c'est toujours
le petit coup de pression pour moi
l'as cannes 3 qui marchent pas
et la cam 4 qui marche bon en gros ça va
faire exactement comme hier c'est à dire
que
on va prendre le risque de faire sauter
live en rajoutant les calmes en fait
très concrètement
je m la partie d'alireza mai mais
rajouter la cam va nous faire prendre un
risque
il ya eu que 4 1 chez ali reza et c5
donc c'est une sicilienne
sa senaka
évidemment la seule calme qui marchent
pas c'est celle d'ali reza
c'est magnifique en fait
en fait y en a une sur quatre qui marche
pas à chaque fois et c'est celle d'ali
reza
bon
je vais être obligé de prendre un risque
donc le live peut sauter potentiellement
on va vous m'entendez mais il se peut
que il se peut que ça fâche crache sa
phase crash parce que parce que leur
truc bug c'est tout à fait possible
bon on prend le risque
le risque est en cours
allez on va essayer de la rebrancher
est une nouvelle fois ça marche pas
c'est ça le délire
bon ben on va on a exactement le même
problème qu'hier
non mais c'est assez hallucinant en fait
ouais
faut le micro compte entendent
maintenant il allume et way you salut
tout le monde salue la francophonie
c'est le kof c'est parti ces partis vlad
comme comme hier un problème technique
mais barré mais qu'est ce que tu veux à
terme dans le cadre d'une ligne que j'ai
jamais compris vraiment en fait
est ce que tu veux que je te l'expliquer
wasit en fait tu prends de la dame pour
centraliser tadam et s'ils l'attaquent
tuque ou cheval et tu reculera la dame
tabac tu vois c'est simple c'est un
profond profond
alors donc c'est les cercles avec les
banques ont les lignes n'est pas tout à
fait central on peut dire qu'il est
fidèle à ses habitudes
donc à d'ailleurs il faut noter aussi
que
malgré que ali reza a construit un
répertoire très solide récemment aurait
donc y compris eux cinq contre quatre
c'est la deuxième fois déjà au cours de
ce tournoi qui ont déjà de l'ouverture
le monde
veut gagner quoi parce que toutes les
danses et les veaux lieu je reçois alors
aozet reçoit majorque avec noir mais il
ya la variante intéressante celle qui
avait joué great chioukh enfin celles
qui jouent et carlson contrat est un
chèque avec d'amd de b3 à b2 ah ouais
c'est avec cole est ce trop rigide au
deuxième et bien sûr elle est
intéressante mais un seul avec un relief
trois tulle a plus non
non ici tu peux pas les voir je peux pas
l'avoir oui parce que toutes les ds et
donnait pas développer elle était de
leur réinsertion ap londres comme ça ces
données pas à maintenir le cap à l'est
sur trois pour garder les opinions est
libre il va sur une soit sur trois fois
sur quatre mais c'est une variante avec
dan d2 elle est intéressante
oui bien sûr maintenant alors je pense
que les coûts principe pour son soi que
les c6 tout de suite et des bijoux des
fausses infos de 7 dans deux-trois même
que parfois près que les c6 les blancs
jouent dans métro a tout de suite
sinon à six est très populaire pour
partir ou b5 or voilà ou s'ils ont bien
il ya comme les fils maintenant aussi
donc en fait je ne sais même pas ce
qu'est ce qui est mieux je pense que
tous les trois coups seront plus ou
moins les mêmes que l'été quoi en tout
cas ali reza qui réfléchit
qui viennent est ce que tu peux partager
s'il te plaît l'intérêt je partage
entente avec toi
d'ailleurs tokyo qui viennent en train
de le faire je peux partager avec vous
que géographe youku
surlendemain singer est donc en fait
partager les impressions sur hyères eux
màj cueillir s'éteindront de très
intéressante sauf les partis d'autres
comptes rapporte qui a été juste une
partie
les warblers ou et les wafers on a des
fidèles et leur niveau qu'on sait que là
quand j'ai fait le récap en fait la
partie n a aucun intérieur lequel ça ne
donnera tout en rapportant même pas
envie de regarder tellement c'est faible
en fait mais bon c'est les warm-up boys
se sont voir me paie tous les deux et
cavalli c6 joué par ali reza
je refais une tentative pour la cam
donc ça peut ça peut faire sauter la
ix20 je préviens tout le monde
ça peut faire sauter live
dans le live est toujours là ça va
et on va renvoyer un an je réessaye
aller
est ce que ça fonctionne
toujours pas
pour le moment pas de cannes pour ali
reza je vais essayer de régler ce
problème je suis vraiment désolé j'y
peux absolument rien
c'était et j'essaye de récupérer la cam
j'ai fait chic et j'ai l'impression qu'à
ces deux joueurs
de
poker
classic c'était une partie à
jouer avec les bons
bien une rapide donc fear is a gagné
deux fois il rapporte à gagner deux fois
donc si vous voulez délicate ans et
rapide
yo yo dans les cadences rapides c'est un
score égal à 2 2 1
et sinon donc une hyundai les partis
classiques donc pour l'instant les
parties conquois se promet de terrain
comment dire est qu'il est prêt au
niveau de leurs représentants par contre
bien sûr normalement un fair use est
favori malgré qu'il joue avec les mois
faut que cinq à six serres tout mais
line très rare justement elle est écrit
pour éviter le type de position au
profit de 74
dans trois pardon montrons peut-être ce
qui se passe après tu peux pas vous
donner 3 jana j'ai si je suppose j'en à
petit rocco faucheux cette c4
que les psys est ce que les trois à six
non un petit rock partage 3 et je pense
que c'est bien ça la cause
principale de cette souriante là donc
les taux de mariage ce qu'on appelle un
appreil comme ça les pions sur 4 et 6 4
contre un pion qu'on baisse les taux
demeurent asie donc justement à 6,7
inventé au plus haut niveau par rich ou
justement pour éviter ça parce que
assises force juste les bandeaux pour
prix sur un an c'est ce que j'allais
dire il y avait quand même un moment
où s'y rapportent avec vous un coup
comme fou ces quatre pour reculer ça
aurait pu déjà terminé la partie or ça a
été vu quand même par richard mais bon
forte c'était le premier moment chaud de
la partie quand même la ddt d'accord
alors maintenant qu'est ce qu'on en a
maintenant les yeux noirs
elle jouait à cinq
maintenant les banques pures reçoit pour
ce sens que même
après quoi il ya un coût assez joli il
est tellement moche que mme joly m6 avec
le 2e 2e 5
d'ailleurs cette formation de cinq pour
bien l'activité du fossé
n'a pas joué cinq sections c4 les taux
demeurent aussi aux petits roquets était
prêt si ce n'est pas vraiment étonnant
ou sinon combien plus en c6 pas tout à
fait oui mais l'idée est là
donc maintenant je suppose heures 5 sans
trop se poser de questions
dans bouge quelque part je pense que
d'habitude du loup le push vers p3 là
après les questions st je pense que
valait 6 un truc comme ça et maintenant
sur ses 55 ans a décliné de 4 donc les
bombes avant tout pour ces cinq jours
plus tôt je pars collstrop tir au chrtr
plus tard et 6,5 pour casser alors se
structure depuis un an avec
les peintures baissier s'associer
souhaite donc je pense que c'est bien ça
à l'unfcu oppositionnel de cette
position bien sûr le truc franchement
analysait je sais pas quel est l'état de
la théorie ici maintenant
je sais pas donc d'un truc ne marche pas
encore pour les pour les imageries
dommage
très dommage
alors l'un maintenant un petit peu plus
tard je vais vous dire combien de fois
j'ai pas de réponse mais je pense un
problème là-bas donc on va par prendre
le risque de faire sauter live on va
attendre
en tout cas les réseaux c'est bien il
joue et quand même assez vite fait à 6b
prend et la c4 il réfléchit mais ils
essayent peut-être se remémorer ses
notes c'est peut-être une surprise pour
lui aussi cette variante de toute façon
j'ai l'impression que richard il joue
que des petites variantes 1 cette
position n'est pas
au sens dit cette fois
prêt toujours les noirs jouent eux cinq
ici encore une fois je me répète pour la
deuxième fois déjà à les raisins monte
son approche agressive même avec les
noix
il est vrai que ça fait deuxième fois
d'affilée que son adversaire
n'appartient pas
au plus haut fort
joueur de cette compétition il devrait
donc ni un jabot parents ni rapporte
aujourd'hui
fait une tentative pour les cadres ça
peut faire sauter le live à chaque fois
je vous préviens
ça nous a refait frise
salaire de toujours pas marché
apparemment ils disent que ça vient nous
mais en fait j'ai l'impression
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression qu'on va pas réussir à
voir la cam aujourd'hui c'est aussi
simple que ça
je vais essayer une nouvelle fois de
redémarrer le truc je vais reprendre un
risque et je vais je vais essayer puis
au pire ça redémarre à la y va on n'y
peut rien
on n'y peut rien
ouais
ça rend assez fou
ça rend fou vlad
ça rend fou
ouais le life qui tient bon mais désolé
c'est un petit peu agaçant ça m'agace un
petit peu on essaye de rester pro quand
même
mais ça ça ça nous fait du stress quand
on live ea
je vais je vais essayer d'écrire je la
sage cela se meubler de seconde
en fait ça peut être une fête il suffit
il suffit qu'il ait quelqu'un qu'ils
soient connectés se fait juste pour vous
expliquer pourquoi ça peut marcher sur
d'autres live c'est qu'il suffit qui
implosent d'un d'une autre langue ou un
plot quelconque y soient connectés sur
la caméra en français et et ça me bloque
rémois pour mon flux sur sur l'url que
j'utilise donc en fait je suis dépendant
des plots il suffit qu'un moindre chloé
et
un plot enfin un emploi à comprendre la
priorité sur moi et et me bloquer
l'accès
donc je vais essayer un coup du j'ai
probablement way
bon ça sur un peu on laisse va de
regarder donc il ya eu 5 da me 3,1
valade
il ya eu cinq heures dam des trois
arrêts
la dame en un vus par rapporte nous dit
b toth il l'a vu ans a menacé la
d'amendé 4 brad richards rapporte qui
évite tous les pièges pour le moment
mais ça joue bien
oui donc en fait
ici dans ce set est passible moi je
pense que c'est vraiment pas la peine
comme alexis seul donc cavalier c3 sans
aucun doute
et peut-être après faut au 705 déjà
possible
qu'est ce que ça donne de 55 au
bon sommes par contre ces questions en
appel est-ce que même
en arrivant à la structure des pions
avec le pion s'est fait brûler est ce
qu'il y ait besoin seront mieux vaut
donc les pertes de fou de noir pour moi
c'est questionnable avant je suis pas
spécialiste j'ai jamais les et c'est
pourquoi à l'époque où je me rappelais
pas quoi
même ce qui est un peu surprenant pour
moi c'est que firent usa
réfléchi aux tempes ausculte
interloqué comme moi en fait elle se
rappelle pas d'unité
sinon aujourd'hui je voulais
comme moi je comptais radjabov avec
libre et
je me suis fait le look sdau vérifie
alors secours de les partis classiques
avec ses couleurs la comcom mach aller
boire et radja le noir
on pas na kham mène 3 0 dans
la cadence voici qu'avec les bancs donc
ceux qui ont dit oui alors anna grand
favori aujourd'hui compter raja pour
comme ça peut-être aller le voir prendre
le
drame de ja
je vais essayer de mettre la cam fasken
sûr question réussir ou déjà ça peut
couper d'accord
ok c'est ce que je peux faire de mieux
les gars ce la seule solution que j'ai
mais qui est pas une mauvaise solution
en fait
ouais ça je peux faire oh bah oui quand
même streamer professionnelle ou la
nickel
l'argent est là
les un petit peu changé
sa coupe de cheveux non
non je pense que non ça ça s'appelle ne
pas faire de coupes de cheveux il fait
pas changer ça c'est l'absence de la
coupe de feu le fossat va jusqu'au bout
non mais là il ya un problème au milieu
non howey c'est un truc assez bizarre
paraît qu il a fait deux fois remet mais
pas du tout réussi quoi
et je peux même mettre une deuxième qui
en fait je peux avoir la face calmes sur
rapporte aussi on reprendre on peut
reprendre le risque après de faire
sauter la came avoir 2 2
oui soyons nous mêmes eaux que c'est moi
les secours
on va laisser faire ou déjà joué quand
on aura besoin elle va faire que valait
il réfléchit 1
mais pour jouer avec les bois en côté
fois bien non aujourd'hui encore une
fois si je me trompe pas les gens mais
battu avec lebron dans une partie
classique il est vrai d'un très grand
secours avec les bons
dans les cadences rapides mais un
classique
y avait que des nuls
ou bien doute à jour on de dingle
est pareil avec les bancs et pareil le
nombre tout avec les
avec les pointes à cet article alors
donc tu as un seul favori clair
aujourd'hui donc n'a qu'à compter radja
bon sinon nous tous on espère qu'ils
offert usa
léger ou grands fabricants
il faut bien qu'ils soient remet à pain
mais c'est vrai qu'il a pas l'air il a
pas l'air coiffer mais les gens disent
qu'il avait peut-être la même coupe hier
mais qu'on n'avait pas la même gamme
c'est vrai qu'on n'a pas eu les mêmes
comme ça c'est qu'on rêve par contre je
pense que ce que cette construction qu
elle a sur sa tête alors évidemment je
pense de moi et le pittoresque
owens et pittoresque ferai ce que cela
est grotesque
cavalli eu cette oie qu'elle soit pour
la rétine mais il doit connaître non
vu le jour
mazeau il adore faire estime qu
à moi je ne pense pas qu'il offre pour
helsinki pense qu'il le faut pour jour
que vale justice est comme ça ils
défendent le où
il a peut-être joué comme rapporte hier
pour g6
et avant le cavalier bien nous pourrions
en avoir eu vent que vous aussi
aujourd'hui jouer comme on dit tout est
ok il va faire cavaler je suis comme ça
il défend son plus haut sur cinq contre
cinq arrivant et bien sûr il joue sur le
fait que maintenant ces cinq cette dame
à 5
g et dames se 5 pouces ce qui pas si
clair en fait encore
ce 32 génie si jugé ici seraient
les joueurs note leur coup et ça c'est
obligatoire en cas de litige c'est la
notation de la partie qui fait froid
après ce serait pas obligatoire dans ces
tournois là mais voilà c'est une
tradition
on dit qu'à roanne a lui aussi a sorti
une prépa aujourd'hui
j'ai envie d'aller jeter un oeil quand
même
temps s'il te plaît parce que j'ai rien
vu encore à part deux feront alors
donc
d'un juke au piano pourquoi pas mais peu
importe vous voyez ça un adieu mille
fois au et
ça on a déjà vu aussi
moi non mais ça jamais la carélie g46
déjà vu ce genre de truc toit où il
mourra bon moi car mon coin à peut-être
pas dans cette position précise mais
généralement c'est pas mon voyage à
jamais du collège 4 lié à 12,5 après je
sens que mon genou n'est pas une partie
guy roux avait fait ça ou impossibles
poissy pour lui après la frh s'inquiéter
repartions h6 avec le cheval il avait
joué pour g4 the witcher mais pas dans
cette position précise mais par contre
pour arrêt essayons de comprendre les
des clients avec l'amant tu veux faire
quand les francos les trois sports
qu'est ce qu'ils voudront
ils le
pas un coup avec cinq jeux se pose
peut-être autant quoi
et qu'est ce qu'ils veulent on va vite
le service qui vient de jouer car elle y
est fin et pau a
c'est que veut pas dire du tout qu'il
connaît les trucs parce qu'il leur fait
que l'éléphant dans tous les ferrone
tempo alors maintenant peut-être alors
que mal et je crois
est bon locaux qui ont un grand moteur
frère ex amant ce que voulait e set mais
je ne sais pas le coup de l'article
quand le set ça donne envie de dame
nature fait quoi encore leurs sacs se
penser ça mais nulle part donc
intéressante d'ailleurs parce que il est
vrai qu' aussi il réussit à pour ses
rouages 8,5
à la dame elle sera mieux placée en g7
en vrai que tout est simple devenir
dans judge quoi pour les bornes en
revanche si caruana gagne aujourd'hui
avec les noirs sont nés peau il va tout
de suite est énorme favori du tournoi
sicard au grunge ici fabien escalona
pardon oui oui bien sûr qu'est ce que je
l'espère ce qu'un run à gagner qu'est ce
que je l'espère un allez allez à l'air
fab y
va et d'aléas attend c'est pas du tout
ton poulain fabi bas j'ai rien contre 6
mai toi c'est digne normalement oui mais
j'ai comme anti rejet c'était un peu
pour la en amont multiplient comme
interpol en multi oui oui je suis multi
amour des polyamoureux
à plusieurs si si c'est
ok mais pour qu'ils descendent du nord
attend une question est posée par
rapport à nostra vlad us ou est-ce que 6
6 1 des partages entre caruana et firent
ouja ouais tu as quand même gagné ton
ostrava la douce parce que tu as dit que
s'ils avaient des partages avec dingli
rennes tu garantissait pas que diglee
rennes gagne mais ce que six un
départage sans dingli rennes ça compte
aussi
surabaya cette porte de sortie en faire
ici un départage comme tu as dit que
c'était pas sûr qu'est ce que tu veux
pourquoi est-ce qu'on montera d'amour a
obtenu une telle notoriété parce que ta
peau indiquent à l horizon pas dans un
soucis à me critiquer les religions
guingois un peu partout quoi
inquiète donc en fait il ya des partages
sanguine glee rennes 50 au cycle tu as
toujours su en fait
non qu'est-ce que ce serait bien s'il le
gagne avec le noir et le pot avec noah
et écouter ses équipes tentent de
vérifier
est ce que c'est à paris que j'avais la
critique vérifie
moi je vais jeter un oeil très rapide et
très furtif alireza sap a joué un côté
warm up
to casal pas joué non plus côté néo peau
ouais plainte et retombe sur ses pattes
mais bon il faudra qu'ils aient un
départage quand même donc il y aura du
stress jusqu'au bout
déjà monde très chers amis ici après p 4
quand les jeunes avec une nouveauté
mais j'ai panique se dégager 4 ici mais
je ne sais pas j'ai pas surprenant non
pour moi oui pour moi complètement pour
moi c'est même révolutionnaire
ok maintenant
je me rate c'est d'après moi turgot non
mais c'est surtout d'un même système g7
qui est bizarre
tout ça en fait j'ai l'impression
qu'elle peut contempler
avant on peut faire trois choses
éternellement oui contempler le maire
contempler les gosses content que je
jouais et peut-être contempler la mer
plutôt la main le maire s'est aussi quoi
ouais c'est la mer parce que l'on est là
l'air fin dans where de la ville
d'accord
je suis pas sûr si tu le contemple soit
résoudre oui oui c'est vrai nous laisse
mario bros comment s'appelait indiqué
mme c'était brochand avant prochain
avant ne m'ont pas donné l'envié de le
contempler alors contempler les gauchos
et
contempler la mer et essayer de
comprendre les autres de coûts
différentes à l'italien quoi dans
l'italien piano parce que malgré les
tentatives depuis six ans je suis
toujours 4e et 7e au 4e ou 5e 4e
plus qu'une heure trente cinq années
peau d'ailleurs il réfléchit sévèrement
dans cette partie
et il a joué ses 5 richard
houis a
parlé récemment ruiz celui à l'urne au
stream parce qu'après damas cinq tomes
c3 est vu à entre d'aller finale
non mais il veut il veut jouer une
finale contre ali reza mais quand il ya
beaucoup de casse alireza il n'est pas
si mauvais en fait c'est surtout les
finales très technique ou issus un peu
et radjabov nakamura oh là là un an la
sueur il est déjà quasiment une demi
heure de réflexion à ralph à cette
position là après ces trois fronts
possibles de ktm j'ai connu et c'est
connu ici que par exemple le cces
manning s'est cogné quoi il doit juste
se rappeler et messi sera très bas
c'est pas trop compliqué dans
des ça comment quand je dis eu des 5
attendu oui oui c'est bien ça
veras patients qui s'en rappelle
equidia intel comme lui tu sais kevin
j'ai un gros gros doutes ludwig qui
doute pas il a déjà une demi heure de
réflexion anglade donc s'il se rappelait
il aurait peut-être un peu plus vite que
moi je vous ai dit et dans cette partie
dans tous les cas maquette en grands
favoris seront tous les stocks
je vais remettre un peu ali reza quand
même il a joué cavalier g61 ils rentrent
pas dans la finale alireza
un certainement pourquoi
s'éprend d'apprendre à me prend fou
prend
il connaît encore tu penses ou pas où il
en impro là haut
[Musique]
voici plus possible bien sûr très
possible ce cas il a l'air de faire sa
tête comme hier quand il connaît nos
eaux et huawei d'après l'expression de
sa tranche oui oui il s'en souvient on
peut dire d'après son expression faciale
est plus français
adacore est désolée elle a d'ailleurs
j'ai l'impression qu'aucun nageur que
ces déchets et c'est de se rappeler de
ce qu'il connaît et regarde toujours
à droite l'hérault à droite oui mais si
vous attaquez à une gentille mais que
satisfaisant mais à des raisons en fait
suivant vers vous tu regarde avec des
yeux tu actives différentes zones de ton
cerveau et cannes il se rappelle là les
gens regardent la hourre à droite ce qui
est peut-être bien le corps
tu vois donc il ya quelqu'un qui est des
fois tout le monde
parce qu'il n'a pas compris la blague
il a défendu parce que toi tu as compris
et lui n'ont
[Rires]
malheureusement
c'est comme ça qu'on reconnaît là
c'est comme ça qu'on reconnaît les gens
qui mentent jeu suivant l'endroit où ils
mettent leurs yeux
donc alors
à fusil à pompe spécimens de nos vies
modernes
alors j'ai regardé un petit pot donc
l'idée révolutionnaire
fabien non
jassem pas avec les troisième ligne
tandis que le collège 4 pour l'instant
donc on comprend rien parce que pour
l'instant on ne voit pas là la
profondeur du truc parce que pareil que
les bandes sont justes mais à quoi donc
ça doit être à alors les préparations
riz quatrième sacre est intégrée quoi
beaucoup beaucoup trop complexe ouais
ouais mais comment ils font pour trouver
c'est lui qui trouve personnellement ou
c'est son entourage parce que fabiano il
en a quand même beaucoup plus que les
autres donc ça donne l'impression que
d'abord c'est peut-être des autres ou un
autre plus tard il a appris comment
faire et maintenant peut être à moitié
des casses viande ou et moi mouais bah
ça arrive aussi peut-être dès le début
de l'été et la note est capable
l'énergique parce qu'il est agressif
justin elle paraît un peu fantasque
parce que d'habitude vous permettre de
telles
libertés quand on sait par où kelly ici
quand même cavalier 4 km 6 2 7 6 a fait
perdre beaucoup de temps à dire 'ok il
faudra faire encore ou achery pour
pousser le 5 et
donc on parle de cette position là dans
la partie à leur nez pour
fabiano qui est très important parce
qu'il les deux se sont payé
28 heures heureuses de hyères sont déjà
des favoris avant le tournoi et en plus
ils ont gagné tous les deux et en plus
ce n'est pas gagné avec les noirs
howe est
donc demain alors locaux [ __ ] logique
sur la poignée de terre
et s et le coup qu'il a man vo fait
recette des quatre parce que
ces prêts par contre l'action sur les
durs aux mélodies prise prises on
caresse de lecavalier ses six ans et
juste pour montrer va prendre du cheval
et donc des fous b2
qu'elle est hyper compliqué où il joue
maintenant mes amis vous savez en fait
fabien époux est en face d'un dilemme
parce que
il comprend très bien pour moi
que des catins coûts principalement
sûrement le plus fort par contre il
comprend aussi que c'est l'élève sait
les lignes les plus analysé pour son
adversaire et maintenant alors donc
rentrer donc
dans la suite principale ou éviter mais
au prix de thiriez détériorer les posera
donc c'est toujours ceux souvent d'un
deal entre durée résoudre en fait pas de
la partie comment il fait fabien ne vous
sera plus doux tant de choses
ça sent trahie par sa s'entraîner ja je
pense que sa mémoire n'est pas mauvaise
d'emblée m et puis ça s'entraîne aussi
comment vont se doit d'ailleurs qui m'a
mis au courant mais après demain que ya
des champions du monde de mémoire et
même s'ils sont nés avec pas mois le des
capacités mais on nous on a amélioré
beaucoup aussi quoi au cours des années
et h3 je dois grandi ici et je veux
vraiment g4
je veux vraiment g4 quelle est l'idée
c'est que kiev après agf au g4 l'idée
c'est que dans ce qu'elle est la tour
sur deux n'est pas top c'est ça en fait
elle était positionnée le corps et du
truc
on va revenir un peu sur ali reza enfin
on peut refaire un petit tour on va
quand même rester sur un réseau c'est
quand même ça qui nous intéresse n'a
qu'à fuir ou de chasse à naka radjabov
sa clique
vite pour le moment
duda ding
a oui ou cette ligne là qu'est ce
qu'elle est à la mode depuis des années
revient sur ali reza écoutant
ok maintenant dans cette position là je
pense que les réserves à faire semblant
de réfléchir bourquais petit moment me
voient sûrement bouffer avec le vous
quoique je sais pas est ce qu'il ya des
raisons de dire si content que ça parce
que quand
est ce que c'est si
propres coiffe ou trois je suppose puis
cavale et pau 2 2 puis tour à saint
louis sur corner 4 tu vois sur ce 2 ce
qui est marrant c'est que ça ressemble
vraiment à la position de 12 ans
rapporte i owe ça fait le deuxième vous
accueille au virus a cherché à la
tempête mais est ce que il est bien
fermée les fêtes
bonne question c'est vrai que ça fait
deux fois m'a pris et lui n'a pas encore
eu les blancs dans ce tournoi c'est le
salin fair use a jusqu'à présent dans ce
tournoi c'est carrément de la baume au
coeur
non mesdames prend des six dames 3e rang
des six par contre aux trois photos à
[ __ ] c'est toujours un concours ya pas
de meilleure case que ça pour
[Musique]
elle c'est quand même mieux pour les
blancs ça
je vois pas de risque oui tu as un truc
un rayon c4 oui c'est chiant fait oh oui
donc on va les recettes comme disent nos
spectateurs prof
[Musique]
au parfois elles disent ma pauvre pauvre
enfin il souffre aussi
[Rires]
avec de hauts mais paraît pas dans ce
cas-là
mais du coup c'est quoi les vannes de
l'ordi latin grosse turbine a dit quoi
ici
pour savoir un peu où on en est il a
pris la dame
il a pris de la dame
d'ahmed
taille sport ici je suis amoureux de
vlad j'imagine que tu espérais lire je
suis amoureuse de vlad
ses connaissances
donc là je dois me rendre ici je suis en
train de cech
si on a la cam normal mais en fait la
can / alireza l'est pas plus mal à la
rigueur
j'ai envie de dire
en soi
soit c'est peut-être pas moins bien on
voit bien alireza rond là en gros plan
on pourra éventuellement rajouter un peu
plus tard richard si on a si on a le
goût il est beau gosse alireza
complètement
elle est quand même assez beau gosse
il existe la marque boss mais est ce
qu'il existe une marque propose dans une
bonne question
c'est pas si mauvais quand même pour les
fringues mascolo là non
non il a l'air il est quand même assez
beau gosse
est ce que tu penses qu'un jour pour un
ordi qui donne une éval ordi et humaine
voilà ça ça ça c'est difficile parce que
lord il est trop fort
et côté qu'est ce que j'ai à dire ici
que soit faute de 6 soit 2,6 soit moins
à 5 et après un push sur à 5 avec les
deux fois ci elle est voilée plus ou
moins un
petit microscopique quelque chose mais
peut-être pas de gros pour les bras par
contre il est vrai qu' au pas de risque
non plus quoi
moi même après microscopique oui mais
chiant quand même non un microscopique
oui mais peut-être trop contre la crise
a beaucoup
pas vraiment non sens là mais
mathias et les microscopiques d'ordi où
il fait nul facile mais où quand et où
c'est relou à jouer ouais ouais ouais je
peux décrire leurs réserves ponctuelles
pour les noix
ce sera dur de l'obtenir mais juste
andré bru si les noirs par exemple
obtient un truc comme ça
c'est simple quand on voit les fluides
comme les six chronos des quatre
là d'ailleurs on pourra obtenir un truc
même mieux quoi
j'étais en transe est en train de dire
pour les caméras de pardon je disais que
le rêve de noirs ici se joindre à ces
cinq ans le fils qu il est aussi ce qu
ils étaient quatre
et ça c'est le rêve on en est loin
oui mais on est à deux coups de cinq ans
même
au bout ok
oui c'est un rêve
je veux pas te contredire en fait rien
que pour contredire n'ont jamais arrivé
en fait ouais
ça tu vas pas y arriver
on serait alors il a affronté alors à
la tactique et les stratégies
à
qui comment dire qui est souvent
utilisée contre des gros tacticien comme
dès le début son adversaire assèche les
petits lancers ils peuvent le faire
quand ils ont les blancs évidemment mais
quand à lire ezzor à l'est blanc ce sera
une autre limonade une autre rue où pour
l'instant voir ce que va bien on voit
loin de ce qui double les noirs et les
assécher toi
vas-y monteurs des capacités de calcul
des capacités tactiques extraordinaire
tant que un beauf il reste que ce qu'il
en reste coi
je suppose d'ailleurs dans sectional les
points en commun plus que dans les
finales
résultante de deux lévriers de change à
l'estérel et blanc ils ont quelque chose
quand même
permis quelques par contre le taux final
les noirs mon père de faux oui par
contre
ouais mais bon la structure est telle
que même la paire de fois elle compense
pas tout à fait en tout cas les blancs
zéro risque mais bon c'est quand même ce
global mans nul ce genre de finale avec
un bon jeu
j'ai bien aimé sa façon de jouer jana
faut 3
f 6 tirs au but à 5
tours 7 touré 6 après que moët dawn of
ou sur u 6 3 sur 7 est sûre quand les
sécateurs tu joue tranquille moi j'ai
parfois eu cette
poussée cette terre
ça c'est assez cool way
de manière de jouer
les doses sont possibles par contre à
5-6 c'est pas le truc le plus évident
souris mais si tu connais jean pareil
si tu connais
oui mais c'est pas en fait s'il connaît
c'est facile
tu y crois pas trop en fait
oui sûrement dû au fait que cette hausse
est de 13
mois t'as pas besoin de temps pour te
réapproprier la position pour être sûr
de pas se tromper il ya des joueurs qui
aiment bien prendre leur temps dans
l'ouverture
dont ils sont pas sûres hier ils étaient
vraiment sûr content radjabov là ça fait
un moment qu'il n'a pas révisé il essaye
de reconstruire son fichier dans sa tête
non c'est pas une petite et tous ceux
qui aiment ça ce sont des gens qui
parce qu'ici je sais que tu vas faire
cavaler hausse est que tu te fasses quoi
mais lorsque les points après que le set
on joue pas 5-6 de grandes possibilités
c'est pas sûr qu'ils les mecs quoi faire
se sentent alors tu vois donc
tout sourire et puis tu réfléchis sita
preview donc ou alors des junkies quoi
c'est pas non plus mis trop trop mal
autant il a mis 20 minutes pour 10 coups
ça pourrait bien sûr quand a que deux
heures avant mais n'en sais rien mais ça
passe à passante passante on n'y croit
pas du tout
qui est un junkie hockey crèche ou que
tant de gens qui est j'ai l'impression
que
vos restes de gens qu'il doit être
jean-pierre
est ici qui selon radjabov a été john
key et métrage solution peut-être
toujours leur disque famille est déjà
mieux
à ilafy la cgt une faute mes photos
qu'on laisse espérer que ça n'a rien non
plus d'ailleurs je mets sur le
voici voisine maintien c'est ce que
j'avais décidé que c'était le plus
logique voilà
une pompe près fait un devoir montrer à
son rôle à son vrai niveau quoi mais
l'épreuve de fabiano c'est quand même
autre chose à un autre monde épreuve de
fabien pour propos pas où
c'est pour ça qu'il peut être si
dangereux en match en fait mais qu'est
ce que j'adore c'est technique de mire
des le tournoi avant le candidat c'est
fantastique alright ça doit entrer dans
tous les textes pourquoi c'est vrai que
sa partie contre maxime j'ai rarement vu
une partie aussi mauvaise de fabiano en
dix ans
elle était ridicule sa partie contre
maxime non mais vraiment tu l'as vu oui
la toile a commenté anne saint bris mais
ok mais ces niveaux 2000 max en fait oui
peut-être à fort kent state il prend les
piles de spécial dans ma tête qui veut
juste se chauffer qu'il en a rien à
[ __ ]
que pet
peut-être qu'il va pas que l'on tournoi
quand il va avant les candidats
et qu'ils utilisent de l'énergie avant
et après les parties voilà coup là où
candidat sérieux sérieux oui oui et
peut-être il ya des pilules qui donne
lui ferait bien plus tard
donc elle a commencé de les prendre il
ya un mois et ce qu'ils aiment ou demain
que se joue quoi celle des cosmonautes
quoi tu voies possibles possible les
pilules une commère fournie par un
certain iron mask a peut-être que pour
les candidats il a des pilules qu'il
faut qu'ils marchent un mois avant et
pour des telles qu'un but car s il a des
pilules qui marche pour 15 20 minutes
il a deux types de pilules en fait
qu
est
ce qui expliquerait
non mais c'est vrai qu'ils jouent
vraiment mal dans les tournois avant
mais gens réellement
bah écoutes je vis à gré c'est pas trois
mois pour jouer à nouveau à chaque fois
tout qui sait en tout cas il ya un truc
hein et alireza qui al'air dessus et
quand même
fou et 3 répartis connais pas du tout en
fait
donc à
nos amis a annoncé avant qu'ils ont donc
l'idée c'est peut-être tout de suite
peut-être un couple terme l'idée c'est à
5 thomas si c'est comme ça qu'ils ont on
voit contrer les décors les potes de 2%
alors on peut vraiment faire cette idée
parce que les blancs n'ont plus de fous
de cases blanches donc la tour sera
intouchable aux importants quand même la
tour appartient à la caste des
intouchables
saïdi se verrait-elle savamment alimenté
par an sans tu as et
c'est parce qu'il fait
mais oui c'est intéressant de remarquer
que c'est la deuxième fois qu'ils ratent
complètement son tour aller qu'avec les
candidats et c'est la deuxième fois
qu'ils
l'attaquent fort quoi
mais tu sais en fait
gary a écrit plusieurs livres
fantastiques
l'épreuve du temps deux matches elle ce
terrain sur moi il est écrit un pl et
aura des
livres pas bien je parle de mes grands
prédécesseurs et cetera malgré près de
madrid et ses soeurs
je ne considère pas que peut on pas bien
par contre et là jamais décrit ce que le
plus intéressant pour moi et prendre mes
collègues c'est comment il se prépare
préparer pour les partis voir les matchs
où les tournois décisif parce que
presque à chaque fois elle est trop tôt
pour savoir et c'est ça le plus
important à comprendre
apprendre pour l'humanité il a fait quoi
vraiment du pain frais de mandat n'a
jamais parlé aux gens nadal comment il
fait pour tout le temps être fort un
roland garros les doors pour votre
peuple et aux rabat désolé
non mais c'est intéressant par exemple
nadal qu'est ce qu'il fait
oui tout à fait pourquoi comment il fait
pour tout le temps passe trop pourquoi
est-ce que je parle des pilules de
cosmonaute illico newkirk pouf les a
menés pendant les matches pour le compte
c'est connu au juste c'est connu c'est
même pas
[Musique]
mon fantasme quoi donc et kasparov au
leur
et carl scène ouais oui tu t'attaches
pas des pilules et spéciale pour des
goodrich proche du joueur norvégien
peut-être que la seule différence c'est
juste qu'ils sont beaucoup plus forts
que les autres en fait
et quand ils ont vraiment groupes
d'intérêts le pouvoir rien d'original
juste les offres de saumon surtout
c'est peut-être qu'ils ont juste un
régime alimentaire plus stricte et qui
font plus attention à leur hygiène de 3
volts en a peut-être qu'ils arrêtent
complètement l'alcool et et tout un tas
de houle au contraire je pense je pense
c'est possible par contre
peut-être qu'ils ont une préparation
différente puis six blessés qu'au
cyclisme aussi ils ont souvent des pics
de forme pour pour les grands tours
l'intéressé ouais mais ça doit passer
par la diète déjà en premier le toute
façon tu es ce que tu manges est-ce que
tu bois fondamentalement
d'accord c'est ce que tu manges est-ce
que tu bois
donc probablement déjà déjà
l'alimentation ça doit être quelque
chose de
très strictes et très très bien gérer
votre main un pur moment changer cette
phrase là alors tandja c'est ce que tu
prends comme les pilules quoi regard
nous on a mangé une petite soeur à midi
on s'est quand même mis très très bien
ouais t'as pas fait
il ya aussi la motivation il ya tout un
tas de choses qui rentrent en ligne de
mire en ligne de compte
est ce que le style est hâtive
concernant les femmes heureuses c'est
vrai et qu'est ce que vous avez comme le
stéréotype de fans russes
répondez-moi
directement s'il vous plaît parce que
moi je connais plusieurs
[Rires]
belles
mama mama terme elle
matérialise pas encore ils m'attendaient
celui-ci lui dit matérialise c'est le
gars qui t'a brawn de fortes poitrines
caractériel
non mais c'est lui qui est fou
c'est lui c'est lui qui t'a posé la
question et si on tous les sous
vêtements oui
oui oui oui les dix mois terroristes du
matérialisme bah écoutez dira pas plus
que les autres si vous voulez il est
vrai il ya des chasseuses belle
chasseuse excusez moi il y en a partout
je connais pas
nationaux n'y a pas de chasseurs voulait
se serrer type n'est pas tout à fait
vrai je vais dire papa yaya touré lire
maintenant malheureusement t'es pas une
proie
sinon
en page plus haut quand il ya déjà sur
mon propre expérience qui a créé
l'événement au coût de poids
à moscou par exemple éléphants sont
nettement moins de brio par exemple
ainsi pris donc puis les hameaux dix
enfants
qu'elles sont très bonnes russie otan
russie - gilles jamais presqu'été donc
la russie c'est très grand
quand même avant quand est il est
minuit à moscou à 9 heures du matin la
diva stocks
du coup quand il est 18 heures avec
niveau stax et canards à moscou à nice
[Applaudissements]
s'il te plait pas de question que les
saints n'ont
toujours su away
combien déniel russie sûrement plus que
rien que sur le caucase du nord donc je
pense qu'il est il ya plus de 40
ans dit qu il trouve pas il a il n'a pas
à 5 à 5 tours à six y réfléchissant
clairement bas à 5-6 écoutait carrossée
louis
caron saint-louis
d'ailleurs
cramique jaune possible chroniques âgées
impossible firent usa à 5-6 ici désolé
mon cher ami mais je pense problématique
je pense baky oui c'est possible et
figurez-vous un kiwi figurent aussi
votre pion est sûre à cette fois sur 6
il ya beaucoup plus de chances que vous
trouverez bien parce que le pion fait un
seul coup mais c'est humain pour voulait
pas bouger le cul bientôt voir c'est mon
en bas quitte new le couasnon d'en-bas
qui a cinq tours à 6 oui c'est sûr en
fait pardon baky c'est sur bouaké
possible oui il a de bons réflexes folle
dans ce type de pose de prendre parti
dans ce type de pose il est vraiment
très très fort breaké à cinq tours à 6
son blitz
si on peut les têtes même en boulettes
on est sur un possible écoutez vlad
non mais c'est intéressant pour moi quoi
elle va réfléchir maintenant parce que
les positions est sèche
les positions et ennuyeuse pour le noie
pas pour les vendeurs
les positions qui au départ les gens
n'aiment pas de jouer là il se fait
chier ça se voit
comment est ce qu'on y met à genoux et
générale comment est-ce qu'il va
chercher les dynamiques lorsqu'on y
regarde bien le pion à
alors je les regardais le dos dames
celui des trois qui le regardent le plus
opaque woippy donnerait le regard des
colons bricolage et même s'il regarde le
calme après le voit à 5 mai avec les
deux fois ci c'est pas tout à 6 en ce
qui regarde là bas
ils regardent le huawei laird hyper
triste les hyper triste ouais ça le fait
chier mais plutôt avec qu'est-ce que je
joue
droite quoi ça le fait chier
d'ailleurs est ce que pour réfléchir à
l'ale dame tu es obligé de regarder la
dame est ce que tu peux faire une feinte
du regard genre tu regardes un droit
j'en suis une fan du regard pour ton
adversaire lazaoui les fonds madoff
ouais c'est le truc préféré des formes
un truc paulin enfouis salle à droite
regardez comme ça pendant plusieurs
minutes à gauche d'être suffisante en
plus par contre au oui à le préparer un
coup eplf à la droite de regarder
pendant dix minutes à gauche et puis
cause et puis comme ça tu vois acf car
les enfants font ça oui excusez moi
monsieur à 5 excusez moi il regardait le
pion a toujours su à baho jouvray avoué
amanda victoire morale kyo quand ils
voient photo ça tourne maintenant mérite
toujours su toujours su pour une
exclamation toujours su dans le chat non
non non non non non non j'ai pas donc
pas encore non non non j'ai pas donc pas
encore messieurs non messieurs tellement
tu as vu il a remis ses lunettes en les
faisant ainsi un petit wang quand même
un petit oiseau passe à jauger asymco
désolé monsieur
mais j'ai un fort soupçon après des mots
kevin tu m'as dit bac fait c'est
directement celui de n'importe quelle
cadence à beaune est ok en disant ça
vieux tu dire toujours qu'ils ont bac
pose pas tav pas pour rire
tu l'as
ya tous les nids aujourd'hui tu les new
mais quand est ce que tu vois finalement
allez-vous est quoi
un bac il a pas besoin et on causait des
grosse option sur
les cages de trucs et que ça se comprend
mais là pas le droit de dire mais chaque
journée j'aurais quand même de plus en
plus sortir les vérités qui voit
fuir vos tous égards beaucaire fei fei
non monsieur
dont monsieur la beaucaire faith
important il connaît pas de toute façon
bas qui
bakhit façon il y réalise les affiches
rouges à connaît pas et est revenu
en tout cas il aurait fait à tempo à 5
tours à 6,6 leur ai vu c'est sûr
beaucoup trop son style
il doit pas être bien là rapporte parce
qu'à mon avis rapporte tout raciste vu
sa partie d'hier lui la paix oui là il a
eu tout froid sur son temps non en fait
pour le moment il se sent très bien pour
le moment et laroque fois ci ce tour
c'est un roi 17 cavaliers des deux ça
c'est la ligne ouais bon ton d'aller
capable de calculer quoi
il va pas être un compte il va y avoir
rock et qui va jouer un f6 tour ses
entours assis là il va pas or je suis
vigneault dans un endroit où les gens
jouent pas money we you
oui c'est vrai là il n'a pas être bien
là c'est vrai que c'est pas comment de
remanier quoi mais il jouait il joue
pour la roumanie ou la hongrie qui n'ont
pas compris en fait non moselle et
maintenant il est vrai et les partir
deux sur la liste de l'hérault manier
puis assurer le vois jouer non seulement
il a encore le drapeau
pour le moment mais peut-être la chose
comment dire peut-être les fidèles et
fédéraux mais au maine n'a pas encore
envoyé leurs jambes hâlées fidh parce
que maintenant je pense qu'ils doivent
envoyer 5 millions pour relisez un tel
transfert je pense qu'après que kerry
king est devenue rude je pense que j'en
ai posé une nouvelle règle si je me
trompe pas
puisque on se ferait pas
1.1.1 ouverture
après après une heure de jeu
première d'accord le petit pont
ouverture a résumé après l'heure de jeu
de l'ouverture d' ali raison alors
maintenant on fait et depuis sa
naissance rapport est capable de sortir
n'importe quel cours ou premier le 4-2-4
que les trois choristes roi peut trois
jeux 3 et même fenêtre je suis sur le
nez capable de 4,6
ok cette fois ci ils jouent eux quatre
sûrement content qu'il soit allé réserve
à sortir les variantes s ur tahir de
l'espagnol sait que quand le c6625 faut
5 ou bien il va jouer les variantes
rosir sur le sicilien donc ce sens que
des six des quatre cd que les deux
cadres que les vielles ce que laisse
croire que les c6 donc il est décidé de
contrer ça avec des handicaps qui
d'habitude même opposition beaucoup plus
calme il est sûrement à compter sur
jeanne que les c6 faut pour s'en [ __ ]
de cette dans d'étroits puisqu'à l'aller
2-2 mardi c'était sûrement
son idée - après pour 5 furieuse à la
contrée avec sa prépa est rejugé depuis
trois ans il ya quatre ans développé sur
moi pas avec stupeur énorme qu'avec
quelqu'un de confiance aux call of à
l'époque qui a travaillé avec les
iraniens ya quelques années donc à six
fausses et s'il bossait avec l'idée de
crier tout à fait une autre structure
les noirs ont obtenu une paire défaut et
maintenant vise à jouer le pion sur 1,5
puis soi car ils se font sentir auxois
e5 comme celle que les justices fawcett
petit roux dont comme un rapport a
répondu aux avec les citerai principal
parce que sur cinq dans des trois
cavaliers cette c4 5 dans le 3e set il
répondu tout de suite ce 5 squale est
dès à présent à saclay noir pur pas
gagné depuis on pense que dans ces trois
dames se retrouvent encore l'histoire
quoique ça va nous mener plus ou moins
haut moins type de l'opposition kurde à
la partie compte de la partie parce que
après ses 5es les réserves pointures
comme les jeux 6 cd d'un v6 d'un v6 sont
et ce qu'ils font ou trois très logique
parce que les points pris part qu'à
l'est d'autres simples et maintenant à
cinq avec l'idée de rencontrer tout ça à
lectoure et 6 à 5 3 points d'exclamation
bon mémoire elle sera paul ii sur nos
analyses analyse très poussée vlad
évaluation pour terminer la position
égal
merci
je n'ai pas fait trop rapide un peu trop
longues aux [ __ ] désolé je veux
travailler c'est le sahara salé
découlent ok mais trop rapide jamais
plus et rapide millerioux nantais s'est
déboîté want what associés pas tous
comme ça pour devenir seul un mouvement
à la fois quel est votre budget ça donne
à peu près ça va je pense que quand il
avait chanté ce refrain en studio je
pense qu'ils ont dû prendre une roue et
logiciel est vendu
parce que je vois ce que c'est sûrement
après eminem il était vraiment doué est
vraiment doué pour l'avoir écouté en
bataille
ils étaient où à la cape et on a
cappella il est vraiment incroyable
à matmata et joe les questions
intéressantes du côté peau en maintenant
aussi c'est un swap fait après petit
rôle après le tir plutôt oui son avis à
tous entourés six mètres et au cavalier
mais un sur deux ou moins de regret r3
sûrs d'eux
ils purent voir une différence en fait
parce que peut-être l'autre cavaliers
donc voilée sur trois peut-être quoique
cette case n'est pas hyper intéressant à
il est possible aussi que l'un des
cavaliers vont aller sur p3 maintenant
et l'autre va se terminer plus haut
calibre en voici ramenés des 2 6 4 il ya
des trucs comme ça aussi des trucs hyper
gourmand et parfois sophistiquées à
perdre gourou mais peut-être même cour
mais même
après foxy qu'il est tout raciste pour
le monde sépare en fait en vrai
on n'est pas sûr en vrai c'est bien que
tu dis ça non mais on n'est vraiment pas
sûr
note c'est pas moi qui le dit mais cette
fois ci on n'est pas sûr mais on n'est
pas sûr que rapportent les non plus
tu peux s'il te plaît montrez là juste
pour quelques secondes comme en fait foi
billets en train d'écraser son
concurrent avec le noir
il n'y a pas eu de coups
il est déjà presque une heure du mois il
vient juste de faire tour à 3 ok en
cèdre issifou les vraies mais après
quand les décades quesque eu lieu on se
demande s'il allait répondre c'est
courir c'est comme que c'est
souvent la vie que ses élèves
gossip de roanne avait l'habitude de
demander et dites moi je n'en ai qu est
ce que vous aviez de calculer dans cette
position là ah bon j'ai compris rien
pigé le truc le plus drôle que j'ai lu
dorfman c'était dans un vieil oran paie
chaque ouais je pense que c'était une
partie entre joël lautier et christine
flir j'espère pas me tromper de noms
mais je pense que c'était cette partie
là c'est un vieille europe et chacun et
après 20 coups à christine était mieux
contre joël la notation de iossif est
dans cette position on ne sait plus qui
est lautier et qui est triste
[Rires]
c'est que je sais pas très bien
ce musical
dans la punchline du mythique en fait
c'est pas moi le temps lui aussi fils à
des pelles peak
2 peak d'ailleurs
j'aimerais bien des milieux naturels et
un petit peu sophistiqué où
elle n'était pas bien pantin et lyon 2
olimpia télé star je pense que 13 18
avec juillet et pendant le tournoi joué
les dire
écoutez iossif quand on voit rentrer en
france j'aurai beaucoup d'histoires à
raconter sur toi quoi
aussi flairé point diot moi aussi
j'aurais beaucoup de stars à compter sur
toi moi pour ce n'est pas l'histoire
mais rassure toi moi pour cela j'aurais
besoin d'un échiquier quoi
[Rires]
filer
ce qu'à moitié c'est une rumeur
elle fait mal typique dans son style ça
fait vraiment un moment moi ça me font
mal quoi
when i là il a des très très belle
plaine d'alsace
maintenant alors il sert qui est le
roman a maintenant peut être au four et
coloré pour mon
spectateurs que peut-être un petit roxy
vous de la part de noir n'est pas très
très bon dit quoique peut-être savoir
oui c'est bizarre c'est la ligne numéro
on leur dit j'aurais dû penser que c'est
un coup de merde en fait
c'est bizarre en fait que leur dit m
non mais la ligne d'ordi c'est bizarre
il fait cavalier des deux fois aux six
cavaliers j'ai 5 pouces et 8
c'est le premier coup de leur dire de
transmission mais c'est pas le premier
coup de la turbine qui est important
parce que petit réparée juste vivre la
turbine non quand même plutôt m6 pour
garder l'eau
le papier au centre
comme tu dis pour que le papy fait de la
résistance
et sa bande de cinq aussi
vieux que le cavaliere ne sera mené sur
ce cas c'est la blonde g5 aussi
rappelant que je sens qu ici c'est en
gros ça plante puisqu'elle carélie pour
revenir on le sait est aussi en vrai oui
oui
d'ailleurs à un moment donné faut qu'il
faudra absolument acquis au
virus occupe de son cavalier sur justice
parce que ces points là où le toit est
après il peut arriver qu'un relief 4
dans leur âge il peut il promet à tous
et parfois de fausses 4
disons que ça va donner une certaine
liberté ça dépend de la pause
oui bien sûr ça peut être ça peut se
faire
j'avais bien aussi aimé dans les blagues
et chicken la blague de kasparov lorsque
short s'est qualifié pour jouer le match
championnat du monde contre lui et qu'il
avait dit le fameux tu connais forcément
it will be short and it will be chou
weight normal on allait demander d'aller
match final des candidats qu'ils voient
ce que les filles contre vous it will be
chant et quel sera le résultat et les
tickets duo que short and it will be
situe au butor ouais ce qui était très
drôle
mais tu penses que c'est pas de lui en
quartiers à pouvoir les shorts et la
famille
c'est vrai qu'il ya des belles punchline
et ça l'a été oui
ouais
bon ça quand même l'air de pas si mal se
passer d'eux pour ali reza finalement
s'il fait deux nuls aux deux premières
avec les noirs ça peut être bien après
mois ce qui commence à main qui était un
petit peu c'est fabiano parce que si
fabiano commence à deux sur deux il peut
être juste difficile à rattraper
pardon fabiano peut devenir difficile à
rattraper si marc lépine tôt ah non non
non je veux que il obtient plus trop
après trois rondes s'ils demandent aux
coiffeurs ou et voilà quoi et donc au
moins deux ans 6e coiffure ou qu'ils
gagnent pio x qui fait le barrage quoi
est ce que tu penses que carlson
accepterait de jouer le match contre
fabi où il va dire ah oui bien sûr bien
sûr parce que même si on a gagné son
match contre miami l'accueil au départ
qu'il avait pas vraiment canon et leur a
vraiment gagné donc bien sûr il vaut
acceptation
et dans ce cas là le lendemain laurent
de moi j'écris of a big one
x qui joue cette fois que je suis prêt a
dit je t'aime et tu sais toi tu peux lui
envoyer la chanson ti
[Musique]
[Rires]
il va comprendre de quoi tu parles
écoute c'est une belle journée pour le
moment il n'y a que des bonnes nouvelles
dans ce début d'ouverture et à hikaru et
ce qui revient dans le tournoi ou pas
sa propre aujourd'hui paraissait assez
infantile puis assure qu'ils seront dans
son cas moins que d'être été très
maligne en fait parce que il a choisi
une ligne qui était populaire calmes
radja n'a pas joué et la page eu presque
pendant 3 à 14 ans
c'est là que cette ligne là était
populaire donc c'est marrant d'ailleurs
de regarder les uns des cadeaux de
l'adversaire n'était pas actif et piqué
c'est d'ailleurs l'une des techniques de
préparation donc si
vous voyez les volets avoir des
réflexes sa cinquième français très
frais ok mais alors un niveau ça fait
ainsi un bond un bon conseil malheur
niveau ça peut pas marcher niveau du
chat
ok
en fait alors niveau d'un porte quel
prépa poupas et
si la coque l'essaïon si après ça ils
nous préparent eux
en fait la moindre idée quoi mais juste
quatre premiers ça suffit déjà qu
il a joué avec 600 alireza
opinion non mais je t'ai dit je suis
très confiant ouais le diam et tour
séance est sûr que ces tours à 6 là
ok mais nous sommes maintenant oui bien
sûr ouais tu n'iras pas fait de vagues
de sept fons possède au fond de cette
allée firo où elle et vire ou même
aujourd'hui je suppose que c'est plutôt
terre à l'effet d'ouvrir la nuit quoi ok
mais c'est un peu nul aux deux premières
avec les noirs c'est un excellent
débutants et parce que au début
de 2ème partie de toujours aller y aura
en compagnie de jouer contre les devoirs
map os avec les ben quoi
c'est pas mal de voir tous d'avoir un
tel atout dans leur manche
il faut chaud là non ouais pas de la
partie mais ici chez nous oui mme des
nuls comme des plots on est qui va les
battre avec les noirs en fait
ils peuvent même battre quelqu'un à un
moment donné
ils peuvent même
donc il réfléchira porte là il a compris
rapportera 6 et sur
annoncé sur twitter l'un des oiseaux
quoi déconcerter plus d'un
mais c'est un peu des plots
j'aime bien le mot plomb
salle décorée comme lloris un plot je
sais pas je vais te dire mais tu sais en
français que c'est un plot
non non pas du tout un plot n'est pas
tape tu vas voir un peu c'est pas un
pleutre
un plot c'est pas un pleutre
si tu fais photo on va te sentiras des
photos de plo quoi
un pull autre
vague qui cherche
ce qui est un plot
h pile k-way ça doit être subtil qu'un
gars comme à dire c'est peut-être un
cours plus fun que pilote bah oui c'est
des plots quoi
c'est une expression qui vient plutôt du
foot parce qu'à l'entraînement au lieu
d'avoir des défenseurs pour t'apprendre
à dribbler tu mets des plots
week se voit l'expression châteauroux
existait pas trop non grosse journée
aujourd'hui j'ai appris ce boulot mais
pour nous en fait line en fait de bâtir
un plan originel et sarianne paris et le
plus original parce qu'il est dans tous
les gros tournois et on sait jamais ce
qu'il y fait
donc c'est le plus original ah oui tout
simple et moi demain le grand moment
voir arriver
à temps la peur qu'ils fassent ou 17
c'est ça non c'est pas que je pleure
mais que une fois la tour est sûre et 6
ça y est je te dis que tu as gagné quoi
et pourquoi pas d'air le plus lourd
ancestrales
ouais paris en fait c'est le premier
plan
pourquoi les dents tous les tournants à
rien grâce à karlshamn je sais pas
pourquoi il joue autant de tournois
ariane paris bon il joue déjà tous ceux
en norvège mais il est même invité à des
choses à voir comme bike pourquoi tarit
pas parce qu il est le compatriote du
hutu chef quoi
qu'est ce qu'il ya de sûr c'est aussi
simple que ça bah ça marche toujours que
toujours comme ça aux échecs depuis que
les échecs aux
impôts à la call girl you want akwa
douala corléonais quoi
vert à l'accord léonus
[Musique]
tour c1 mais du coup parfois quand je
vois un plot dans la rue je pense à rien
de paris maintenant
réellement
mais le dur je marche il y avait un plus
au milieu de la rue si ça te dire
décoller sa photo j en fait ils font
quoi rien aussi cool il a fait sa photo
est pris
je refuse mais il n'a pas si mal joué
norway d'ailleurs
bizarrement
lis pourtant ils se détestent les deux
saumons fallait voir les poignées de
main à au norwich s ils se détestent
ça m'étonnerait
il a assez beau gosse
c'est 5 il le déteste
ouais ouais c'est vrai que ça explique
ça peut expliquer ouais c'est bien loin
de personnes quoi
avec nous ils sont pas toi et ça
m'étonnerait qu'ils soient papote
d'ailleurs l'ordi donne la même mais
valve pour fou 17 août ou raciste mais
c'est tellement tour ah si si si oui
mais quand je dis tour et si c'est si
moche que ipic pourquoi
howie dorough 6
c'est comment dire
c'est comme si tu veux te raciste c'est
con car sans qu'ils voient sur les rues
avec des rires oui
[Rires]
mais en fait tu penses c'est magnus et
et ariane
c'est peut-être le plus beau joueur de
haut niveau aura rien a ainsi pu aussi
se présente à rousies oui au moins six
que la russie est pas qu en russie pour
y être soignés et c'est bien connu
non mais ça se voit qu'il est beau gosse
d'ailleurs je n'ai jamais vu un mois
j'ai jamais vu en vrai non plus mais
quand tu vas sur la caméra ça soit il
est vraiment beau on est vraiment
donc si tu veux ou tu veux tu dire
qu'ils ont pour la
vulgarisation de ce chèque au machin
machin paupérisation ont sonné mois
crier battu fait un terme à l'atari ici
pimco et jules moussa jeu le mot ça
me plaît de merguez
nom de l'une gaz aussi en fait dominguez
de ya 15 ans
mais jules moussa récipient nico et
aérienne paris où elle est très inégale
au quatrième autre est un peu rudement
et toi t'es qui je suis de manquer ce
matin mais des plus beaux noms je suis
2015 de ya 15 ans
c'était vraiment beau gosse ouais
ils disent tous bords pour être
mannequin
ouais je suis patient francs loin de là
non
je
n'en
aie baki oui évidemment et pas qui
sait pas qui
qui serait hors catégorie comme
mannequin pour pied à paris
mannequin pour prier
à vie dit aussi
est non si ici m'a donc
c'est beau quand à toulon et qui
discutent dans le chatt maintenant
dit-il valent pas le prendre non plus
c'est sur le cerveau tout à fait
d'accord mais alireza en vrai
si je pense comme des discussions
sérieuses quand même
ouais mais c'est que la coupe de cheveux
le problème tu lui fais un petit
en vrai large
on va on refait un petit tour sur les
game
eaux et sur les games donc quand les d4
faut de 4h trois
bâches s'opposent ça donne envie de
jouer que les 1,5
et là il devra bouger sont fous quelque
part leur dif ou de 5 x 2 ok long chose
est claire keim tour à 3 même si pas
dans le top 10 est un coup intéressant
parce qu'il ya un bon groupe la tourbe
éventuellement série minella quelque
part vers g3 sinon je suppose qu'ils ont
ici son point général c'est de bouger
les rois qui comparent virage arrachant
joueurs cadres après quoi
supposons joseph fourcade colère sens
trop abondante donc les noirs doivent
faire quelque chose de
entreprenants et rapide et où il compte
alors l'idée de rush à 9,4
donc
je suppose doit être pas si pour le moko
après six mois je ne sais pas quoi
on verra on fait un petit tour mais le
conflit est très intéressant oui oui
gris choc trop de charisme on dirait un
personnage de roman de cs que tout à
fait il ressemble à celui qui a tué la
vieille femme dames le livre le
tout à fait bien sûr tout à fait
il donne un pion c'est d'avoir abattu
fatigué on va peut-être venir
instantanément dans le tournoi
hockey d'armes de cinq feux aussi faux
insiste dame sait si ce procès
c'est plutôt quand même votre
laissez pas juste gagnant ça
non c'est pas gagné mais je suis
d'accord je vois pas trop de
compensation jeter derrière pas fou et
si cela est si un pouf
tour en que voulait un des leurs fous et
sans que je sais ça ressemble plus à la
vérité oui sauf que bas à dax où
fourcade
se pose on se chauffe au f4 et là je
perds pas le pion à jouer un tour terme
parce qu'il faut eux 6 et 6 x 2 oui donc
bizarrement je vais où je siège au plus
bas ici c'est moins que m6 etc bien sûr
c'est mon coeur - servez l'autre c'est
juste une touche à owen pas intéressant
alors
l'accès michel strogoff je sais pas et
qui me suis trop excuse moi
ici par contre ceux qui sait tout
d'adding comté pitt hugh dowding mal
préparée c'est pour ça et que les roues
à mapou et donc hélas rien obtenu dans
l'ouverture mais
elio comme d'habitude caennais connaît
pas la pause il vise le roux aurait donc
les projets sont coralie et vos pouces
et f4 et aquariums
ça va être dur d'attaquer quand même
parce que la formation de noir
réagissent les deux donc et qu'est ce
que les noirs doivent faire à vrai dire
je sais pas peut-être échanger les fous
sur 1,5 parce que le fou sur bussy c'est
quand même un peu trop bizarre à mon
goût est ce que il ya deux raisons de
jouer de 5
je sais pas est ce que le roi sur sept
dans ces cas là oui parce que comme quoi
c'était ce 2e des 4
machinerie donc peut-être pas de 5 me
soit 5 peut-être intéressant je suppose
qu'il faut sur pc c'est un peu comme
trop bizarre a peut-être rien faire en
cours mais en plus offert quelque chose
quand votre adversaire vieux pour ces
conneries ces sédiments à quoi que quand
les recettes les propositions de redire
logique en fait les df 4e f 4 kg 6,6
lofo bouge and alex est allé 4,5 et
c'est comme ça d'ailleurs qu'il joue
aussi sur le fait que l'opinion penche
sur ses cadres pas sûr 3 donc la case e5
tout frais libre les browns en zone sûre
alireza
au oui donc
ce que c'est le moment clé de la partie
en fait c'est le moment clé d'un moteur
ouais ce qui la laisse qu'il a le tour à
6 ou pas
je pense que firoud djabou qui face à
hunter quote
désolé qu'est ce que ça veut dire que
leur cote
je pense que le recul j'aurais très bien
tant je te montre les gens doivent quand
même dans le chatt marc nesme des
requêtes
je fais en n2 requête et j'existe
c'est une coupe de cheveux länder cut
assez à la mode ici
non non c'est très bon 4 il faudrait il
faut qu'il fasse oui il faut oui oui
bien sûr leur cuir est très bien roulé
ouais mais passe à ce que hélas rien oui
oui bien sûr me passe à ce qu'il a sur
sa tête maintenant parce que
je boite de je trouve pas de
bornes d'arcade pourrait pourrait lui
aller comme un gant je pense
alors ça pourrait vraiment très très
bien lui allé
en bois ou alors une carte de réduction
pour barber shop non franchement si line
d'orgueil qui va être super beau gazon
d'ailleurs c'est marrant toute sa vie
chrome ni que ça va pas quoi faire avec
ce cheval
est maintenant qu'on croit son élève a
irrité le même problème n'a pas eu à
vendre et maintenant il est arrêté ouais
j'ai pas si l'entourage commence à
m'inquiéter
non ils le voient mersey pas comment
évoluer ça
le problème c'est qu'ils ont tous
racistes pas et pirouette en fait en
quelque sorte parce qu'il parle de
culture c'est quand même pas prêt tout
récent voilà [ __ ] sur les sixièmes
quelques pas du racisme c'est pas une
troupe entre yb loops juste en cours
précise mais bon
d'ailleurs après j'ai pas tout raciste
cette fois ci c'est céréales noir
voudront aussi mettre son plus haut sur
à 4 pour fixer les doutes d'un magret 8
d'ailleurs un enfant moi je suis assez
fascinant fait si tu réussis à mettre en
place c'est vraiment facile après et
pire aux bouchers tout à fait
boucher comme on met toutes les nouilles
pourquoi il souhaite aussi chez par 700
élèves kamali e set c'est bizarre comme
4 nord-ouest est moche
tout raciste c'est très beau - après de
résistance retour à 6 c'est fou 17 de
toute façon aucun value set peut-être
qu'en valais eu cette
fois rapportée aux locaux relié avec un
livre plutôt les verrues 6 ouais pour
ses 5 îles et des cartilages peut même
être mieux après
wii
u reste coi et commence à se mettre aux
normes à l'otan c'est un grand mot mais
c'est vrai qu'ils commencent un peu à
piocher
1h08 26 coup
quelqu'un
pour expliquer tour à 6 bat tours et 6
passes qui cavalent elle s'étrangle le
cavalier passif au à 17 le roi
n'appartient pas à cette case là elle
est trop exposé faute de cette le fou
est mieux sur russie soul tape sur la
pontiac annales dr à six parce qu il a
que ça qui rament
les pièces noires harmonieuse plus tard
ou à vii faut aussi sakata la
littérature donne donc le reste est
fait retour à 600 f 7 et pas bougé le
fou aussi peut-être économe et vite
revenir en russie ce
je pense que si le rajout viendra le
temps où
le taux dans les rêves quoi merci chef
merci il est vrai je cuisine gang
et irréfléchie ils apparaissent à 100
qui calcule pas en fait il réfléchit à
des concepts cela dans son esprit il
n'est pas sûr ou bien il veut se
retrouver dans le times traboules parce
qu il en a besoin
de se sentir être analysés qua non je
pense pas il y en a besoin de se sentir
vivant
je pense pas sinon tu sais dès que ces
murs noirs avec tous ces gens là
autour il se sent pas trace vivante les
bisons de piqûres de raynal et
on ne voit pas le temps par vous dire
une heure 22 ans
vient de retour à 6 donc j'avais raison
où es tu avais raison au maire
mais pour toute cette belle opération
par contre 14 coups joués il était pensé
quand même nom mais sur un jab 14
minutes soit objectif t'es pas bien
belge et piriou je le vois
t'es pas bien
honte à moi
on trouve en qh you toujours su
c'était sûr en fait qu'ils auraient
il a quand même un sacré niveau le
frérot
alors quand même assez assez serein
c'est vrai que sont de rigueur est très
comment dire à
33 inspiré par un truc
[Musique]
franchement il n'a pas l'air inquiète
beaucoup moins qu'ils arrière quand il
était inquiet ça s'est vu
ouais un gros emprunt mais
comment intégrer les qualifiés aux
candidats ont fait qu'est-ce que la au
foot comment intel joue ici
et rapporte aussi il se pose exactement
la même question comment je me suis
retrouvé là ça joue beaucoup trop forte
ou racistes j'avais pas il n'est pas
bien là
maintenant alors si vous voulez ce que
pas mal dans cette position là c'est
qu'ils ont tous les deux pour mettre
l'orchestré bill et moi je mange les
banjos khaled toukan les c4 puis qu'au
volet eu encore les 2 3 les pièces
seront poil too tough louis les noirs
vont mettre leurs voix sur sept coups
sûrs et six points sur à 4 tours bouille
les pièces noires sont bel tout à fait
les deux peuvent à leur frais mais l'un
des plus beaux que l'autre owen on peut
dire mon mari car qu'est-ce que c'est un
moyeu et rigueur mais franck qu'est ce
que c'est je pense qu'ils se regardent
la position ressemble à rien paris et
moi ici piennes cocoyes
et celle des
aisselles donné pomy un chiffre il sait
pas passer mon bassin viol ou quoi la ce
a pas bougé et là non plus on va rester
sur ali reza du coup on se faisait un
petit tour rapide des échiquiers
non mais il a l'air vraiment serein
il a l'air de philosopher sur sa
partition déjà demain ils jouent contre
qui des bandits nous serrons 3 ne nous
montre pas là on a tous disent attention
avec les brocanteurs et ko au
penalty
oui j'ai penalty en moi un coup-franc
101 nous on a une expression ces plots
ou pedneault à allada plus au péno de
mal
ok
ténor pedneault pedneault les amis et ya
un degré supplémentaire c'est pénaux au
lieu du gardien c'est un plomb au milieu
est
vraiment
le degré le plus bas possible
c'est pas trop dur de but est
normalement mais demain pedneault
hockey mario comme un écart ou se
préparer pour aujourd'hui à vrai dire je
ne sais pas qu'est ce qu'il faut
les préparations
tu vas regarde on a les émaux de benno
qui partent
à mais ça veut dire qu'en fait nul
aujourd'hui gains demain
et après demain
alors après on va devoir jouer mais pau
avec le noir
parfait très important
ne commence à perdre qui est cause
soient punis mais qu'ils soient punis
aujourd'hui et se restaurer demain parce
que le mec à ce qu on appelle un front
classé chez les boxeurs c'est frau
fronde en glace ikki qui s'écroule une
fois qu'il ya une fois tu tape dessus
ouais
super aujourd'hui en fait c'est
peut-être déjà fini pour lui le tournant
on se rappelle dans son match contre
magnus
il avait quand même complètement sombré
et pau
d'ailleurs n'est pas bien sûr n'est pas
mieux agir dans tout afin d'empêcher
tout à fait n'est pas
n'est pas mais si tu peux pas ici on
commence à lui demander est ce qui
pourrait pas comment ça m'a jouée comme
messi kenka
ici tu lui envoyer un sms avant la
partie contre ferroudja et que tout le
monde est finalement si c'était pas
n'est pas mieux chi
d'ailleurs pour ceux qui savent pas
mais pommier chi c'est vrai que ça se
traduise sur wii qui sera peut être pas
quoi
ouais on peut le dire n'est pas fait
pour ça d'ailleurs je pense que là bas
elle est très peu de chances de se
qualifier il est vrai il leur faut une
fois moins il se rappelle plus comment
voilà mais c'est un nom très compliqué
qui semble très long et très bizarre non
ouais ouais c'est il ya peu de rhuys qui
ont ceci ce nom de famille quant au fait
que par exemple quatre chiots ton nom il
est assez commun près surtout au sud et
les rues sont souvent des noms enfin je
vois vous dira d'ailleurs quelques
sketches of their c'est pas de quatre
chefs en fait on en sait bien de catch
off
mais oui ils n'ont pas à quand tu es
devenu français ils n'ont pas forcément
traduit de la bonne manière c'est vrai
que nous en france en france on
francise les noms beaucoup quand on les
traduit
et
ce après
mon ombre ce que dalet est réduit et ses
rangs peuvent se tisser ans c'est
marrant je vois différentes bof
tu peux appeler comme ça j'aurai un
contrat
mais en fait c'est vrai que toi d'y
aller krief messei of quoi donc encore
une nouvelle fois on n'a jamais su
mon complexe
d'ailleurs rien à l'acteur qui te
ressembler beaucoup quand il était jeune
ray liotta est décédé il ya quelques
jours
[Musique]
elle te ressemble vraiment dans les
acrobaties il est bien trop
complémentaires si vous avez un message
plus quoique c'est bien trop complément
vous avez vu des photos de vagues quand
il était jeune et que vous regardez des
photos de ray liotta
jeunes qui se ressemblent vraiment
c'est vrai je testerai par les coups de
fer à ce quoi les grilles qui dit à un r
je confirme
ouais c'était un sosie les gens écrivent
c'est un sosie
on les a jamais vus au même endroit
moi j'espère que vous allez dire oui
mais il joue et moi sommes
très bons actes
dans les affranchis malheureusement ça a
été surtout quand même l'ailier qui au
film of you temps je pense que l'été aux
plus grands axes à aller dans les
affranchis son rôle est tellement énorme
balafre il m'adore
d'ailleurs il ressemble un peu dans sa
construction au loup de wall street
même complètement mais c'est parce que
c'est scorsese mais c'est vraiment un
copier coller
est d'ailleurs dicaprio me fait un peu
penser à ray liotta dans sa manière de
jouer bas dans ce séjour les hôtes à
vrai dire je suis pas un fana go
de quoi
un grand acteur lenardo quand même oui
mais
pour moi que dans plusieurs îles mais
bon
je pense à
comment s'appelle la surexposition sur
l'île et qui joua le schizophrène ouais
mais les gens vont dire
les gens vous nous dire dans le tchat
shutter island chapter je trouve qu'il
joue et est extrêmement violemment aux
couleurs ouais il joue vraiment très
très bien dans ce film
oui ici oui et seaway
moi de toute manière je pense que c'est
un joueur c'est un acteur dan d'un grand
rôle surtout quand même parce que quand
même c'est surtout comme danny way
the revenant aussi
il a très bien joué
moi que ça car
eliota cecchi écope annonce john pesci
et psychopathe
ray liotta dans ses finances en traître
quoi
en quelques sortes très drame quelqu'un
qui a compris que tout ça c'est tout se
joue là ce faux
marbres et l'a compris la dernière scène
des affranchis tu vois qui s'est trahi
lui même aussi
jusque autre chose d'ailleurs ouais
j'aime bien quand il ya un truc très
italien je mangeais des pâtes à matri
china avec du ketchup dedans j'étais
devenu un plouc
sépare la fouta exactement ça mais c'est
ce sens là et je m'imagine chez moi avec
des pâtes et du ketchup j'étais devenu
non mais on a le droit de raconter la
fin des films quand ce sont des
classiques qui ont 40 ans ludwig
20 de titanic le fil le bateau coule
il a joué qui a validé deux donc ça
devrait continuer par wife set mais je
pense que vous aussi c'est ok aussi oui
moi jean retroussé 7 puis fouet 6
et on va se diriger petit à petit vers
une position égal
ouais c'est ça le premier soir j'ai
commandé des nouilles sauce marinara et
j'ai eu des nouilles au ketchup je suis
qu'un quelconque minable ok c'est la
phrase exacte la phrase est belle quand
même aux
brasseurs les commentaires de nos sauces
de nouveau le cliché atlantique
[Rires]
[Musique]
la phrase est magnifique feront
quoi exactement tel est parti deux fois
bien non
trois connaissent et six tours à 3 et
commandes après
ça a bien bougé depuis en fait cinq
fauves et de foi de ces cinq besset
qui peut être vraiment très mal fou
prend c'est ça qui touche la tour alors
dit la dr b3 et b5 un haut salaire
terrible en fait
bay 5 ça a l'air vraiment fort
l'idée sur à bab que on touche le x 2
et surtout aussi c'était quoi le truc
torts 30 bessette fou prend à deux tours
prend 1,2 et les cases blanches hockey
est compréhensible
tout ce qui rime comme en fait peut-être
il va rester fidèle à l'idée initiale je
pense que le déni ciel a été de broc et
lofo bois sur radio adjointe de 5 6 4
avant je veux dire il a poussé ses 56 4
mai on dispose pour réfléchir parce que
vous prend ses cinq la case la tourelle
à que la 15e oui mais si on
my turbo france
il faut pas bouger les tours parce que x
3 x 3 dont beaucoup de compensation
comme cannois ouais donc
et de décès tu regardes tous cuba mais
tu veux bouger ses gammes à trèbes et 5
kw et d'ailleurs après ces quatre tu
veux connaître 3 n'oublions points et
c'est assez joli comme une fourchette
sur un peu tout
faby si tu gagnes pas sa
garantie qu jenny blanch
et peut-être cette pâte on rêve quoi je
gagne quoi nous prendre il a pris du
plomb enfin d'hikaru torteron dams et 4
h 3à ok c'est une pause
radja doit être assez bon quoi j'ai pas
faux de 7 euros 8 ca pas été une
compensation site et moi ma shalit et sa
croissance mais c'est plutôt bien pour
nous qui carouge ou mal enfouis que je
me réjouis mais avant demain wet seal à
un demi puis après un demi sur trois
encaissés ce prix il reste toujours
pasqua d'ailleurs il a fait un truc très
bizarre c'est qu'il a posté une vidéo
ce matin
de sa partie d'hier et je suis étonné
qu'ils fassent des récap de ces partis
pendant les candidats
sont des idiots
il aura des instincts de streamer un
instrument mais c'est trop un grand pas
pour voir que jouer pendant tout le tour
il voit alors refaire parfois ses
activités typiques de ces deux dernières
années donc bien sûr comme ça il n'y a
aucune chance de le tourner là bas c'est
trop ahmed bien sûr parce que intérêts
publics
ces trois hommes et adorée du public
quand tu gagnes mais non non non moi
d'avoir le feedback de les publier oui
c'est sûr bah pas blé que des jeunes
gens qu est ce que tu penses qu'il a
peur si la plainte l'attention du public
de re devenir un quelconque minable
va tout à fait tout à fait un jeune
trois duos de regarder les choses dans
le miroir sans recevoir les commentaires
des autres
mac a été le meilleur marqueur le plus
brillant naka
thébaux
ou nakache captifs et way back of my way
ils disent qu'il a streamé hier soir à
m'envoler mais voyait donc oui ok comme
ça d'ailleurs il est plus juste que j'ai
commencé à changer le taux d'hba1c
cassé ou est quoi oui et puis donc et se
trouvaient tous les jours sans aucun
problème
ouais c'est pas une très bonne idée un à
la dépendance
alcoolique sexuelle
n'importe quelles dépenses
ils disent que c'était une redif info de
chats toi tu vas faut pas trop croire le
chat non plus mais la vidéo c'est sûr ça
je les vis à vis de l'analyse à toute
autre manière et loire et
les primes et des renault est le plus
mal et doit jouer le cloud se doit cette
récession
ouais ouais non mais ça va être dur
c'est de toute façon c'était sûr que ce
serait dur comme tournoi pour pourri
garot
mais oui ça veut dire qu'il n'a pas il
est de toute façon il n'est pas venu
dans l'état d'esprit peut-être de
remporter le tournoi
et si cette promenade quoi ici c'est pas
de blabla bla
c'est une manière de faire baisser la
pression aussi je pense il vient en tant
que le streamer il ya moins de déception
s'il joue mal
vous savez
ça change pour ceux qui sont pas que les
filles est d'obtenir des grains jeu ils
ont l'habitude avant les parties décisif
ils sortent graff jusqu'à 3 4 0 et le
monde et moi donc le mec pierre au lieu
d'offrir nul ou gagne le dimanche
barrait pourquoi pas moi vous savez je
suis sorti coiba journée la tête vous
savez quoi
en cadets très bien
ce comportement
waimes à presser haut des douanes et
quand tu perds aussi ça peut se
comprendre
huawei continue dans sa philosophie doit
et donc car j'en sais pas son métier
mais ce n'est pas son métier en soi il
s'est qualifié
il s'est qualifié un peu par hasard en
vrai c'est pas s'y attendre lui même à
se qualifier
qui se retrouve un peu engrenages et
dans un truc c'est pas facile quoi
puis l'on puisse en scène qui leur a
ajouté un genre de bad buzz avant la
partie
eric en scène je sais qu'ils s'entendent
mal avec eric en scène ils ont de
mauvaises
et il lui rajouter un bad boy juste
avant la partie
s'était battu non ya pas essayer une
histoire monde scène il voulait juste
lui casser la gueule
il aurait way et la région les reins
alors de peut-être plusieurs dizaines de
ce qu'ils ont voulu il a je crois qu'il
ya une histoire un les gens il voulait
l'amener dehors allait se battre et tout
est du genre on va se battre comme des
hommes et on va régler ça à la durée et
carbo avait refusé
dans 7 mois et qui se voit le mieux
j'aurais dit radjabov quand même
un qui d'autre duda
way duda peut-être non non bah c'est sûr
que c'est pas digne sûr que c'est pas
hikaru c'est sûr que c'est pas n'est pas
c'est sûr que c'est pas caruana ça doit
pas être alireza non plus
rapportent
ils disent n'est pas
bon je pense que ça fait c'est un
tournoi iode personnes qui se battent à
mamie ou né pauvre et les mamans il joue
pas là oui voilà non mais mam et non non
je vendais l'amène sakurai son p si vous
voulez c'est un moteur de la lutte
amateur de la lutte est d'ailleurs pour
que vous ayez une ip sur ses capacités
physiques quoi quand et jouant comme ce
que le bowling il est capable il est
venu me voir devant moi trois
catastrophes de filet quoi il est fort
le mec
mais ici je pense n'y a pas de faits
intéressants
cavalier e 1
voilà quand je dis d'ailleurs il veut
maintenant il veut maintenant il va
mettre ses pieds sur les prélève case
pareil va être fait par son adversaire
qu'est ce que ça donne d'habitude vous
connaissez les réponses
ici je m'appelle m'inclus ya le plus de
force
aux forces
joe barbaro
qua
non pour pour oui maman oui car c'est je
pense plutôt terne 1 0
je sais pas par rapport à l'expérience
mais physiquement je pense que les
bandits non mais non
riches cui
reach oui oui et ses quoniou
bon après c'est vrai que c'est
clairement baky qui défonce tout le
monde y croit
c'est facile sur cette ligne que voici
que je voudrais c'est non en fait je
pense que pas qui tu sais qui me ferait
penser dans un tel tournoi à steven
seagal en fait juste les autres viennent
et bas qui les met par terre oui il ya
tout le monde sur un bateau dans
n'importe quel film de steven seagal
gens il est là généralement les autres
viennent et justifier de l'aïkido il
aimait par terre tu as déjà remarqué
steven seagal il va pas se battre les
autres viennent et oui je pense que baky
ce serait ce à quoi on en vient le
deuxième et le tournoi serait terminée
quelqu'un a écrit caisse moto lieu
ok je reviens tout de suite tout de
suite à perdre et donc il a joué wife 7
alireza ça se passe plutôt bien pour le
moment pour le joueur français qui fait
une partie sérieuse on l'avait dit un
peu friable
dans les finales mais aujourd'hui il
prouve qu'on a tort c'est plus les
finales technique avec peu de pièces où
il a des problèmes alireza lorsqu'il a
beaucoup de pièces sur sur l'échiquier
normalement il se débrouille pas mal et
là il pourrait éventuellement jeu le
même tour des huit pour pour jouer sur
la colonne et ça pourrait être une idée
le truc c'est que deux bases on voulait
jouer pour tours b 8 mai après cavaliers
c4 c'est vrai que l'option b 2 et très
défendu et donc on pourrait se dire que
le dk la vendée 8 pourrait forcer une
tour à revenir en d1 et donc à gagner un
temps et sur cavaliers c4 on pourrait
remettre le fou en en rang et fuite et
après petit à petit redéployer le
cavalier peut-être vers russie ce genre
disons un coup comme f3 pour nf3 pardon
il ya tant qu en d 3
wade il en coût comme tour des seins et
faux prend ses 4 ok oui en fait c'est un
problème et tour c'est royal france et 4
en d3 ok pas si simple que ça en fait de
juste trouver un coup
ok si on fait déjà cavaliers c5 france
et 5 france et cinq cavaliers f4 c'est
sûr qu'il ya plus rien pourra les blancs
[ __ ] couleurs opposées le cavalier
s'active
donc ouais en vrai tour des huit pour
taper sur la colonne
roi elle fin du coup pour roy e 2 paraît
logique fouet cette 3 e 2 est ce qu'ils
ont réussi à ramener le cheval ans aussi
je crois qu'on a du mal à ce moment là
en fait qu'il faut trouver un coup pour
pour ali reza
l'ordi propose cavaler h4 mais c'est un
coup
pas top top
visuellement
peut-être un coup comme fou c'est 8 peut
être intéressant avec l'idée de jouer
cavalier fuite qui a valu aux six
cavaliers des quatre mais aussi l'idée
quand on décale la tour vous assiste
peut être bien placé
donc ça ça pourrait
ça pourrait être une variante correct
pour le joueur français
tour 18 paraît vraiment être la belle
case pour la tour et sur cavaliers c5
direct bafoue prend ses 5 fu dont vous
pensez ça qu'on peut pas il ya tout
reprend des deux donc tort français cinq
cavaliers f4 vous prend un f4 qui on
prend un f4 on tape sur la colonne sur
le cheval est sûr qu avait laissé quatre
on peut peut-être même échangé rentrée
en d2 avec la tour et on va aller
tranquillement vers un match nul
donc ça ça a l'air d'être une
possibilité
sympathique peut commencer par fouet
cette d'ailleurs à 4 aussi peut être un
point pour fixer et taper
sur la diagonale de 6 à 2 et sur
cavaliers c4 bafouer cette et tour des
huit après et ce pion et quand même y en
a quatre qui se fait pas touché par par
le cavalier c4 et qui fixe le tuant b2
et
pour jouer tour b3 donc il faut prendre
ces cinq j'imagine
à 90 j'aime bien baby luxois barre à 4
c'est un coup c'est un coup logique
fawcett retour des 8 c les trois coups
un
m'vila je suis combien de price mais
pour la vitrine cup alors nous pour
l'événement caritatif qu'on a fait on
avait évidemment
pris 0 1 je le rappelle
on me chasser la plus belle quand même
que ce soit maxime ce soit fable ce soit
baky tout l'argent qu'ils avaient été
récoltés
avait été transférée sans intermédiaire
à
l'association
c'est quand même important de le
rappeler parce que je pensais que
c'était la pratique de tout le monde
mais apparemment ce n'est pas le cas
donc tour des
8es l'association vous avez rien
reverser en retour quand même rappeler
les bases
des navets donner de l'argent moi aussi
un on avait tous donné de l'argent fava
avait donné j'avais donné on avait tous
donné
d'ailleurs
elle avait donné une somme assez arrondi
j'ai plus qu un système c'était
peut-être dans les 500 euros mois
j'avais peut-être donner un petit peu
moins à l'époque j'avais peu de moyens
mais oui oui non n'était pas c'est l
inverse on avait fait linverse en fait
c'est pourquoi la société pour médecins
sans frontières
autour des 8
et on veut taper on veut peut-être joué
fou b4 ou quelque chose de fou et 7
pardon et j'étais enfant me reste quand
même un coup comme fou b4 qui est prend
bécade si on prend les quatre pour taper
à deux est possible
l'ex
fuir vos chances de win aujourd'hui ça
va être difficile mais mais une nulle
partie nulle avec les noirs serait un
bon résultat et away fabiano qui a joué
le fou c5 est née peau qui n'a pas
trouvé un fou des cinq qui a joué tour
b3 b5 cavaliers à 5
ans qu'elle veut quand même joué les
cases blanches ça va être chaud en cette
partie entre yann et et fabiano
duda ding il ya eu quelques coups et
j'ai cinq tours b un cavalier 7b quatre
prises en passant tour prend b3 fou
c'est cette fougue 3
et ding va vouloir faire une expansion à
aller droit et nakamura radjabov
ça a l'air
de se tenir un pur
pour le joueur azéri ce qui serait
plutôt une bonne nouvelle pour ali reza
je pense en vue de sa partie demain
contre contre hikaru
donc tour des huit
du port un soir pas mal ton nom c'est
quand les jours de repos c'est tous les
trois jours il ya trois jours de jeu un
jour de repos trois jours de juin jour
de repos
on attend la gaffe de richard wooding
mac et oui c'est l'anniversaire
d'alireza aujourd'hui un grade qui
souhaitent qui fête ses 19 ans
il joue les bons coups à les raisins
pour le moment non irréprochables justes
est reprochable paraît d'ailleurs un peu
dire sur son intérieur
seront un peu dur car quand il n'a qu'a
obtenu sa place par hasard écoute il a
joué qu'un tournoi de qualif sur les
trois et il était loin d'être favori
donc forcément il est beaucoup de
réussite 1 c'est pas
ouais ouais quand même après avoir joué
pendant tauzin de place au grand prix
c'est pas donné à tout le monde
et surtout que sur les parties il a eu
aussi beaucoup de réussite je pense
notamment à sa partie contre et 6
piennes cas complètement foot où il ya
moins 7,6 père il est éliminé et sa
partie contre paris nos sites
pittoresques manioc horrible de sa poule
et hawaï à 2 par candidat qui sinon oui
les marines voilà c'était il avait une
pièce de mon autre arène complètement
futur du web pierre de 23 coups et a
d'ailleurs très facilement d'ailleurs et
c'est très simple donc on va s y perd
une de ces deux parties où ses
adversaires sont à +5 et plus est il
n'est pas qualifié donc la réussite
après il faut de la réussite pour se
qualifier mais bon
c'est comme ça
quand on joue sur quelque partie
forcément
voilà maintenant
plutôt qu'en valais ses cadres ou plutôt
qu allez-vous 3
oui mais il est là par là moi je voulais
bref un père pas par contre à monsieur
lequel ces quatre sets c'est en fait
c'est un peu relou bah justement je
voyais que trois au moins pour leurs
bouger sur ses cinq plus tard l'âme de
ce délai
je dis pas que ça dans le mental
tous trois et peut-être dans le temps
matériel pour curer les faits
c'est ya plus rien fait pour les blancs
bonjour ce cas présence mais qu' une
partie bien joué par les deux joueurs au
foie voilà c'est une vraie partie de
niveau 1
donc
libre est bien gardé jusqu'à présent
autour de 8 c'est l'homme des coups
possibles moi bien sûr il veut jouer sur
le fait que le coalition de 3 est un peu
instable en stop simmons à royan 2 ça
paraît logique mais y avait un plan
intéressant avec fous ces 8 et fo à 6
peut-être
qu'il pleuvrait à ces cas là tu te
ramène fois sur deux
mais tu as besoin d'aller sur deux pour
défendre jean roy f1 flo7 roi ici ici
même un coup comme fou ces huit pour
faire camani elle fit cavalier six
cavaliers la evora 8 les trois écoles et
s5 est comme ça et tu y arrives pas tu
vas pas y arriver
1 tu vaux d'autres tempos quoi ok je
commence vous doublez
3,3
à être un peu mieux blanc quand même
quatuor qui n'est pas énorme
ça va suffire quand même un
poil et poisseux tellement serré roi f1
classique
la position est trop scène pour ali reza
qui fait une excellente partie
son journal
est autant savent à 55 minutes pour
cette position c'est largement assez 1 à
quoi servent les femmes c'est pour
mettre l'euro en e2 et défendre le
cavalier qui pourrait être attaqué par
la tour
aux enfants si vous voulez mon tour les
instants que d'un bon joueurs d'oublier
parce qu'en politique quand vous
contrôler la situation
et quand vous voulez vous savez les
rangs des sauvages que quand vous le
voulez vous
je pense quoi d'autre jour de samba il
virus y'a pas danseuse russe qui
adore pas je la vend jusqu'à
joas avait touché
un centime aux élites du mentalisme un
sentimentalisme
de coin qui a mal et f4 ici peut-être
jouable d'ailleurs moi je pense que
cavalière 4 où j'ai pas à 4 au fond
c'est peut-être
une dizaine de coups qui sont corrects
même à cinq je sais pas mais moins pas
ces choses comme ça je pense que c'est
juste un peu au moins
[Musique]
rester stand by qui regarde
n'est point non vieux le bide non non
c'est le but de tout dépenser le but de
dida parce qu'ils les donnent le bide
donc l'ami paul ii et depuis tout petit
tout petit ou pas depuis depuis le 8
août la
le bide est présent en tout cas
pas de quoi être fier à moi quoi parce
que j'ai moins que ça t'a -
la rejoint eux
ils disent ce n'est pas non
cette dot a oui à main anna
enterrement
j'ai brisé le sco s'est duda
par exemple politiquement pas du tout
pas un seul gramme de la classe quoi
c'est un beau but vide quand même
c'est un bide au boulot à vouloir quoi
il cache bien la caméra en tout cas
puis tout à
il est joli ce plan avec le bide et fier
où tu as derrière
oui oui très bien pris deux
ans vraiment magnifique ce plan c'est le
plus beau plan de la journée je crois
le bide en premier plan et firoud déjà
un petit peu flou derrière pas derrière
un tel bide de n'importe qui devient
floue quoi inexistant
je pense qu'ils veulent a gagné 1
alireza regarde comment il réfléchit oui
il veut la gagner mais le problème c'est
qu'il ya ici pour perdre les points
doivent soit des connaît énormément
soient accumulés les déconnade
pendant 300 coups pendant 5 ou rui et
l'a donc un peu accumulé quelque chose
donc les élèves en otage mais c'est pas
évident de te connais ici en fait il en
est capable
s ils s'excitent pour l'instant les deux
sont assez calme en fait ici pour
déconner il faut citer
mais y'a pas de quoi
joe boyd
baby just by dj ou d'ailleurs
ça réfléchit sec
mais il a l'air beaucoup plus confiant
qui hier hier il nous a fait peur hein
l'iresa pendant une heure et demie à
réfléchir
à pas grand chose bayer et avec de quoi
calculé ys je ne sais pas c'est plutôt
une question de goût
qu'est-ce que recueillir 10 mois ok toi
perso bref quoi ces coûts ont secoué
cette fausse m
moi perso je n'aurais pas pu me retenir
de ne pas jouer à quatre pour tubes yann
pour du mois elle dit moi que je suis
nulle moi j'irai feuille a4 fait
peut-être fou et c'est 3 2 et 1 4 me par
principe j'aurais enlevé le fou ouais et
cote à geoffrey à 4 quand même que je
suis sûr que je vais jouer à 4 donc je
jouais accueil pour libérer l'esprit et
de ne plus réfléchir tu vois
c'est pas bête
scassa réfléchissent à calcul
simon donc aller reza à 50 minutes de
mire
[Musique]
son adversaire 58,8
donc
plus -
[Musique]
à tien c'est ce que voit sur les pauses
c'est ce qu'on voit en national est
parti trois autres prises en compte
d'après chez que les cinq dames 6 bat il
est bien augmenter son avantage
parce que l'auteur n'a pas compris ce
que l'ordinateur a dit qu' il leur fallu
sacrifier la tour sur a3 pour donc
comment dire il doit
réussir à 3 pour gagner le contrôle des
cases noires pourtant vous il est vrai
c'est pour montrer surprise prise prise
hier c'est pas ton point de vente
puisque le fou et protéger ses x 6 le
problème
ok
duda ça n'a pas bougé depuis tout à
l'heure
et n'a qu'à non plus
values me chercher une bouteille d'eau
et je vais ouvrir fait de plus en plus
chaud de l'année
oui je pense que c'est une bonne ademe
en shot alors fausse cette eau à quatre
roues bien à 104,4 parce que de nos
jours on est tous les élèves de soirée x
0 soit de l'élève doit il choisir donc
magnus carlsen maintenant c'est très
très éléments pousser les pions à côté
puisque ça nous permet de gagner de
l'espace
peut-être c'est important
15 vendre 30 coups plus tard
c'est possible donc donc soit 4h 5h 4 il
ya toutes les raisons pour moi je vais
faire à 4 d'abord et puis
je sais pas quoi
sinon oui il faillit pire choix et s'y
habituer moi pas tout à fait donc mais
grâce à ces stream
je m'habitue
vous les trouverez un pousse à vous les
trouverez où vous choque je pense tout
petit mois dans le rayon des boissons
fraîches à monoprix
on pousse les pions ça derrière les
pièces d'attac
oui en quelque sorte moi c'est surtout
pour prendre de l'espace en fait parce
que il est vrai à quatre ça donc pas
beaucoup pour à présent à 104,4 ça donc
pas beaucoup
mouvement mais peut-être à 40 couples
tarbes en finale deux tours avec le plus
haut sur hk terrain pourra jouer je sais
pas tour à tour à charge doivent
redevenir faible mais c'est ça les
échecs en fait prévoir les choses bien
bien bien bien en avance
bee doo dah donc je le vois pas
maintenant donc je sais pas pourquoi
est-ce que vous reparler d'eux
sinon donc jean bakouma et qu'est-ce
qu'ils sont encore à manage pause oui je
pense on en a en fait donc ananas et
mondialement connu pour perdre du pid
c'est pour ça que
je les aime
choix
est-ce que ça m'a donné envie de partir
vivre en france va écouter j'ai vécu en
france aussi loin que je veux vivre en
france de nouveaux alors ça dépend du
choix il ya les deux chancelade loisirs
alors d'un shot
comme gingembre citron
on attend notre shot ananas gingembre
curcuma
bien sûr deuxième
ouais tout ce que à frauder asic et je
veux toujours pour tu fais le boring
c'est parce que tu es divorcée
spécial
avoir des raisons de fric tu peut encore
y penser
ils disent attention à toi kiev mais
j'ai vérifié la patronne n'est pas là il
a fait tous les quatre comme j'avais dit
on doit dire oui sept non mais après
tout à l'heure quand tu es parti j'ai
parlé de foot et 4 aussi j'aurais fait
recette mais j'ai parlé de foot et 4
makelele dsi les branches au roi eux
deux comment tu veux me punir j'aurais
fait fouet cet après
à kew ce que tu passes
mais je suis dit que c'était possible
parce que l'idée sur cavaliers français
a b c pour expliquer aux gens à d'accord
d'agression deux
bannis des
enfants tilloles
infantile
bon j'aurais dit que le football 4
temps cueillir vos points des coujoux ce
professionnel fouquet's est en cours aux
aphrodisiaques
pour ali reza hélios excepté lui-même
pour rendre cette partie un peu plus
intéressante que avant
c'était juste un coup pas super je pense
qu'il faut qu'on lui amène un shot en
fait
un show c'est quand même mieux que font
nos quatre métiers que ces chocs même
pour jouer en partie c'est pas mal en
vrai
si tu te remets tes aux échecs à temps
pas compris tu veux dire que des très
excitée c'était l'essence propos c'est
bien pour le parti je pense parce que je
regarde si tu veux avoir un design
joints d'autres non
franchement ils sont pas mal comme ça
peut-être une fois le zen au 3t rivaux
étaient très préoccupés par d'autres
activités tu vois oui et non enfin sa
tenue un vrai coup de fouet
à un voyage bedie et tu vois tes rêves
que par d'autres activités tout avis que
lui voue au sens
mais ça n'existe pas ça en russie c'est
chouette je me
son incroyable non a voiture ne raconte
l'histoire de l'anecdote de calcutta
écoutez ça commençait à quelques temps
que je prie une shot avec jean becker
pour moi c'est le début le reste vous
pouvez vous imaginer
ils sont vraiment bons
je pense que jean grenet j ludwig aussi
dans les shots
c'est un vrai plaisir en fait après
celle il ya un truc qui est gênant quand
tu les montres en string que tu bois ça
c'est qu'après les gens vont acheter à
fond et y en a plus pour toi
[Rires]
c'est que des locaux s étaient streamés
russie pour polir que toi oui
simon casas va dire ça sur sa chaîne
tout c'est
peut-être y aurait encore plus de choc
dans le rayon des
conviendrait non mais c'est sans alcool
en réellement c'est juste en fait c'est
des shots pressée à froid
c'est chouette et presse à partir
d'ingrédients
issus de l'agriculture biologique en
plus haut
non ils sont vraiment sympas
lamarre deux choses carte du corps
vous dis aphrodisiaques nantua ses
gardes du corps - ses coups de foudre
ah ah ah oui heureux
foudre
tu vois je te parie sur le devoir c'est
de
[ __ ]
de réécrire coup de foudre en petit on
sait très bien de quoi ça parle et
et quand tu parle de
kevin j'ai un petit peu la peur en fait
je compris sur moder sur de vue
cavalière 4 et ouais j'ai trois quarts
les shader ouais c'est très dynamique
fait alors oui mais je crois que c'est
moi
ou peut-être fou de dofes photocall et
toi non
donc il veut alors que relâche 4
comprend g3 il veut aussi dire peut-être
que cela ouvrira la couronne a en fait
et c'est après fou de dos il voit se
mettre à réfléchir ben dunn avait en
fait 50 mais non je ne veux pas ça
oui mais au moins vous faut sur le canal
ça le problème et du coup là dessus il
veut quoi il me paraît léger si ce
retour
et dire que ça c'est juste nul en fait
par contre peut-être il a un peu comment
dire il a aussi stimulé par exemple les
pré france 5 est peut-être pas tout à
fait prendre sur ado parce qu'à part
défendu continuera de 3 ans et un bébé
peu trop à quoi
bon ok pas de 3 ok
mais ça c'est vraiment pas loin malades
non oui oui si toute proche ça me ferait
pas peur du tout ça avec et doit
pas si près possible
du royaume
dans tous les cas c'est plus ou moins
c'est ce que
rapporte est en train de essayé de
calculer évoluer maintenant
les gens comprennent pas l'intérêt du
format atx ou tard le format c'est
l'idée c'est de le vendre plus cher
ouais d'autres moyens telle boisson vous
pouvez pas
boire beaucoup consommé beaucoup parce
que c'est il perfore comment goukoye
déjà bien trop
qu'est ce que les dynamiques quand même
content je commence juin dans n'importe
quelle position il trouve quand même ses
ressources tactique pour du piano pour
du mal juste jeter un oeil sur les
autres
dit pourquoi ok il dit lundi sur un
accueil tank fou de 7,7 le coucou le
plus évident sur la position qu'il a
fait il ya bien longtemps
et ici ici ici
c'est compliqué juste
c'est quand même si bizarre qu'il ya un
tel londres ou tôt pour le cavalier sur
7 2 sera menée sur des catégories qui
ont par la case réussissent mais il
faudra faire pédaler un sacré nombre de
coups donc
hyper dur d'évoluer menchov qui mieux
pourquoi il perdure
mais peut-être la position de duda
contre diang peut-être
comment dire qu'on doit mieux à duda
parce que je pense que ding si on peut
parler de ses faiblesses je pense qu'il
n'est pas top vale position ferme et
comme je me rappelle comme carlson l'a
écrasée dans un match rapide et blitz à
san luis en 2018 il employait souvent
l'ouverture des cadres qualifiés
simple en fait ok si c'est pas sa
première scène ajoute des cadres ok il
employait l'ouverture comment s'appelle
la défense indien palestinienne indien
où tout se faire tout de suite quoi est
presque à chaque fois avec une grosse
réussite parce que dieng paraissait
d'être bien et perdure dans ce type de
pose donc
alors
ça va pour douze heures
tout terrain
complexe
on est un peu dans le temps dans ces
antres bas c'est à peu près entre 16h15
et 20h30
ouais fait ça ça joue pas mal de coups à
la première heure et après comme souvent
sahara est atteint car la troisième
heure là on est un peu dans les deux
heures de pointe et c'est là où ça se
décide en quelque sorte c'est dans un
second milliard une heure
à jouer dira survie qu'au second
quelqu'un va prendre en grand avantage
ou pas
complètement gagnant va bien j'ai
l'impression à écouter que d'autres
selon m
et pas que selon leur dis mais ça va
quand le roi est faible et vous jouez
contre un gros attaquant
il ya toujours des trucs qui arrive en
fait avant souvent de truquer kerriou
le roi est assez faible
possible de résumer la partie rapidement
tu peux aller sur twitter on a mis le
résumé du vérifier
que ludwig les liens faits
est-ce que ludwig a fait son boulot
le dic a bien fait son boulot donc tu
peux aller sur le twitter est un résumé
de la partie
pourquoi donc marche pas parce que c'est
aux blancs de jouer
donc il a joué roi des deux
bronzes de pardon
et donc tu sais que son idée c'était
probablement car à 10 h 4
baies pas d'autre idée parce que sinon
faut qu'au qatar n'a aucun sens
complètement
imaginons par exemple si les noirs
prennent sur des domaines ou moins sûr
logique
dans ce cas là après fou de deux
prochains coups cavalli 5 et en a obtenu
le rêve et là c'est plus grave parce que
une fois les bonbons je collais se
sentent plus depuis un an sur b3 et
doubler sur c'est donc ça risque les
noix aurons-nous d'offres blesse sur ces
6es à 5 puisque une fois le corps les
est sûre ce cinq pattes d'autres on est
détrôné et les noirs pourront pas
pousser leurs pions sera 4 donc ça peut
être dangereux alors donc aux photos non
c'est pas un coup sûr le moyen de
justifier l'action se gobergent cadre
qui va forcément jouer du coup
qui va absolument forcément jouer
si j'ai bien compris
nos spectateurs
comment toujours le beat de 12 m ce que
je crois qui vient souvent
devant la caméra que moi je rate mais je
crois qu'il passe souvent devant pour
montrer son bide pas parce que c'est que
y'a de quoi montrer heureux
après c'était il ya peut-être d'une
épaule aussi dans le réel gens
d'ailleurs quand la bagarre de bill
entre néo peau et
et duda
ça peut être beau
oui donc le 23 juin
[Musique]
mais pour qui passait de lobbies plus
grand qu'au loto voit donc je comptais
là on n'avait pas perdu un peu du pid
hockey reste toujours mais tu le vois de
temps en temps se solder peau ça
t'arrive de le voir
comme on le dit
tu donnes quand par hasard je veux dire
je n'aime vraiment pas du tout non nelly
vraiment désagréable à ce point aux
fruits il fait quoi de si
ok
ok mais le diable et les poignées de il
est malin livre il est tout quoi tant
que ça le frij est ce que nous
et donc j'ai aucune raison de les voir
si ça arrive qu'un m'a juste bon pour
toi aussi tu as du pif et le wii wheel
vous bien sûr j'ai jamais dit le
contraire
exactement ce qu'ils ont à dire
mais ce que c'est pas pour jouer aux
échecs à haut niveau un
désavantage
d'avoir un peu trop de poids jean
physiquement au coin tu n'étais pas
fatigué plus vite homme très dur à dire
en fait
je pense qu'il ya deux mois la veille
parce que par exemple car il a l'âge de
30 ans peut-être mais elle aura donc bon
je pense que
à dix longueurs
pour réussir aux échecs peut-être c'est
pas la peine d'essayer de se rassembler
brad pitt quoi
bon ça rentre dans la position qu'on
avait
imaginé au maintenant je crois sur pau
ce que
parce que le reste c'est triste
ok comme ça donc avec cette opération il
a forcé les boîtes de données l'excès
opium à 2
je trouve ça bien sûr que les jeux 6 va
pas tarder parce que hier il a eu une
expérience
pas facile à inscrire fiant de qualité
donc non et doit pas répéter ça quand
les e6 donc et le plus probablement
fausse ou cinq élèves
braid pid
kg s'ils souhaitent soissons et cavalli
g2c vraiment pas possible le fou peut
partir si on ne savait pas pousser 5 en
fait ce sera un beau joli coup fone
forêts mais malheureusement après fou g5
lecavalier crie famine
au crif
j'ai d'ailleurs est ce que
je peux aussi regarder comme ça mais ça
marche pas du tout
donc non il a joué qu'un rédigé six est
maintenant alors d'ailleurs à part de
foot 5
il peut penser aussi à un coup qu'on a
quatre
pour crier le plus ont passé ce tube
voix rauque et peut-être tout reprend
bras et les décès bon je le puis en quoi
je me suis trompé jean match à tours 1
et avancé
m dora 4 il est vrai
c'est même si tu bloques icc breaké très
tôt donc plutôt non alors donc
on se sent d'ailleurs un cocon core i3
aussi qu'il
contournait à 8 par exemple oui
car les c5 pour bouffe vêtements bouffe
a
su recoller ces six doubles
intermedia ce qu'on appelle échec au roi
l'on récupère le qu'un malien après
être hausser encore son aile et du bide
mais c'étaient des grands lutteurs
bien sûr comblé comment s'appelle
combler ce parti comment s'appelle
japonais le
souvent oui
comme le sont maurice tu sais qu'ils
sont hyper fort en fait
ouais
alors ils sont vraiment très forts mais
les plus grands joueurs de ce mot il
pèse combien
dans les 200 kg non oh
il y en a qui font dans les 160 170 mais
je pense les meilleurs ils font dans les
deux sens on ya des gens qui vont nous
nous éclairer
à eglisau moins de 100 kg
akkouche h au 275 donc un peu moins 175
kg kembo un beau beda 175
listes rivales entre 100 et 200 en
moyenne 160 le plus gros 285
il fait très mal non
le plus embêtant lutteurs de l'histoire
peser 280 kg et le plus grand mesure est
plus de deux mètres mais certains font
moins de 100 kg ou n'atteignent pas le
remède 70
mais les plus forts entre 160 et 180
caisse est beau quand même
moi je trouve ça hyper protégea j'aime
bien que ça casse les règles d'octroi
pour être
à dire un mot il faut ne pas faire le
région de touba un manobo bien au
contraire quoi
par contre je ne peux même pas moi je
n'ai combien ne faut pour fait par jour
pour y arriver
est ce que on donnait sur ce que tu peux
plus je pense que c'est dur en fait
imagine les pêches que tu poses à 280
qu'il faut
[Rires]
c'est impressionnant aucune
magnifique 1
c'est pas bon pour la santé oms ne dirai
ça n'a pas l'air d'être excellent pour
la santé
ils paraissent d'être très contentes de
leur vie quoi peut-être ce n'est que je
sais pas le mythe de la société de
consommation qua non je pense pas
je pense vraiment qu'on n'est pas
médecin tu vois donc on ce difficile de
s'exprimer sur ce sujet mais j'imagine
que tu peux avoir des problèmes
cardiovasculaires en cas de surpoids et
c'est
visuellement ça a pas l'air cool je sais
pas
si un autre pays h dans le coin c'est
assez la ville la plus fantastique que
tu peux te tais pas bien le célèbre tu
pousses tout ce qu'ils pouvaient
l'espérance de vie entre de 30 à 40 ans
mais par contre l'espérance de vie mais
qui elle vit comme un c belvis assez sur
la durée de vie moyenne d'un sumo
n'excède pas les 65 ans
60 65
c'est pas beaucoup 60 65 ans
c'est comment l'opposition peut être un
petit quelques ports les bois peut-être
même pas si c'est vrai et s'articule
pour liban ce que les banques doivent
être très précis voilà faut ce 5e tour
d'où il comme on a dit avant peut-être
aller au fond des âmes
et lord il aime bien ça mais bon
c'est
que c'est très dur d'y croire il a fait
pousser 5 quand même
ok
pour tout va être fait maintenant
puisque fois dopé 3 et là il faut être
précis calculez bien quoique kowalewicz
au p4 que réussissent bien sûr
possible
mais ce foot à ton bureau alors bloqués
en rade par principe ou à leur tour brut
quoi d'autre
par contre vous savez
dans le sinaï parfois il faut pas trop
de dépêcher les choses parfois il faut
juste rien faire dans les faits me faut
juste attendre et manu vrai quoi entrer
dans les phases de manoeuvre est de 4,4
cebrian et où jean montéro zik peut-être
y jouent les finales comme ils auraient
dû j'ai joué milieu devrait au milieu
d'eux joue au milieu de jeu donc c'est
peut-être pas le taux congrès parce que
l'air maintenant il est il est obligé
d'espérer que pour l'agneau louis
paquiot si leur foi à saint guarato
fawcett oui bah pourquoi pas et si
l'hôte heureux oui c'est le genre c'est
le genre de partie ou si c'était qu'une
scène avec les noirs tu aurais pu
commencer déjà demandé si ce n'était pas
les noirs qui jouait le gain en fait oui
on en revient toujours
au même point fait oui mais bon il à ce
point fait quand il avait noir mais
quand il va avoir les blancs et qui va
voir ses positions il va faire très mal
quoi c'est pas tél c'est pas beau
pointer sur ado parce qu'un fou 3 broc
le faut après
tant d 8 jouer
il a l'air quand même assez tranquille
alliée raisin
je le sens très serein le sumo france
est
intéressant qu'est ce que le cavalier
noir voit apparaître dans cette partie
sur bussy pour cela elle a besoin quand
même trois coups que vous les filtres
faut bouger que réussi
pasquin a dit bien au début du sectional
est que
dès le monde parfois locaux voilier à
partir de la case aussi s'ils y arrivent
les noirs pourraient même être mieux a
rapporté un petit air de kenzy a fait je
trouve qu'il ressemble un peu à orelsan
en fait mais
de loin
ça continue à jouer naka
s'est pas passé grand-chose et duda non
plus
c'est une journée un peu moins emballé
qui est malade
après c'est peut-être parce que là où
est tout à fait un peu plus
un peu moins un peu moins emballé
on les jours passent aussi inséré que
les partis sont longues et hertz a déjà
duré six heures
elle appartient à ces plates way
la partie à ses fins plate c'est une
belle partie de haut niveau mais c'est
vrai que c'est pas il ya en fait tout
pouvait arriver réellement chaque coup
pouvait coûter la pas partir un joueur
ou l'autre là on a du mal à imaginer que
ça se joue sur une erreur
ils disent la partie plate comme le beat
de dingli rennes
j'espère qu'un jour quelqu'un va écrire
la partie est plate qu'on tombe dit ladd
mais ce sera une partie de talent
en tout cas on a tous rambin 8 qui
défendent punto b4
bon je sais qu'avec leur dire bah vrai
dire avec les turbines il est vrai j'ai
pas grand chose à rajouter il donne des
petits quelque chose pour moi c'est
difficilement fille a brûlé je parle de
la partie de fusion
complexe
c'est la dure loi du duo niveau anglade
à hama les mêmes tableaux dont une vraie
on a le bide
ce sera finalement pour le moment ce qui
est le plus intéressant de la journée
c'est quand le bide apparaît
il est quand même assez imposant
alors on est à
quelques centimètres
d'eau 3
une belle brioche
on sent la fierté quand il expose son
bide c'est vrai qu'il a l'air content
il a l'air vraiment heureux
ok comme ici à point de grand chose à
dire est ce que tu peux montrer plus
tard quand même maintenant je monde
accra au ghana qu'à part d'ombré mais en
fait c'était pour nous
c'était une époque c'était pas d'août a
en fait la
wii wii donc d'audace et alors à un
centimètre et demi peut-être est un
impôt solidement 3 way c'est pour ça
qu'il était fier ouais
c'est le bit qui les fait dire à
l'effeuillage ou sans moi tout quoi
enfin bientôt toujours beau gosse quand
même un
désolé de te décevoir mais regarde
en beau gosse qu'on croit que tu dis sur
quoi qu'ils jouent bien sûr toujours
regarde beau gosse de ouf beau gosse sur
10 à léon dalle une note ap ap ap le
chat il est giga beau gosse regarde
alors on met ma attend sa quête jouer sa
route jouer oui donc y avoir quoi il y
aurait 3 h deux voitures jeux 3 ouais
ouais non rush de saint graal et c'est
injouable had
pourquoi deux sur dix noms mais je vois
des mauvaises notes
franchement ces villes beau gosse du
tournoi n'en regarde
excuse-moi maillot pour cause de tournoi
est un drôle de coup comme un fou de
cette fois c'est cool je comprends pas
l'aider je pense qu à quoi ça sert
explique moi il se développe pour situer
les faits refouler 5
ok je pense aux joueurs 4
f24 il va peut-être jouer tour jouit
d'un
troc et moi s'il te plaît 4g
4 on est aujourd hui tout est ok là
maintenant j'ai compris les défauts de
cette et la ligne et c'est heureux ok
maintenant égale et
sipa f4 mot h4 peut-être ça n'a aucun
sens maintenant parce que jojo ok
maintenant je comprends ok donc photo
c'est tout et c'est un coup brillant jeu
développé ses pièces en fait oui oui je
sais parfois c'est hyper dur de jouer
calmement comme l'autre à
l'étang des moines pam a fait savoir que
tu as ta chérie je faisais rire quand
l'autre un tel bide
[Rires]
or ces deux tu vois il anticipe ou b5
peut-être bien jouer des retours c'est 2
il
oui je compris maintenant si l'auteur
fait rien il faut 1 14e épreuve 4 oui et
surtout jour en automobile par exemple
qui viennent ou les autoroutes
à ilham il a libéré les diagonales
oui j'ai passé les libérer les diagana
enfin si vous vous rangez 5 d'un match 5
ok donc le coût normal alors ce soir
bouffer sur cinq soit rejoué ok
maintenant sur tour joseph koala
est maintenant leader avec les deux
tours 5 c'est faux sacs dame aux 57 qui
maintenant je vois ici en cours au
concours 6,8 sur mentaux ce sens que les
décisions à 1.505 vous êtes vous un tel
truc ça je veux ce que te tape donc pas
les avantages mais où il faut c'est
depuis 2005 ok ok donc tous ces deux
c'est pour libérer les diagonales des
anars 5 et pour donc d'après sûr c'est
un coquet c'est bien joué très bien joué
d'ailleurs c'est la spécialité de dépôt
de trouver de tels coups d une géométrie
un peu bizarre mais ça lui convient bien
oui efforts 5e f comme quoi donc
affaibli les cases blanches même si tout
à fait jouable
ef est maintenant au moins d'une menace
plus fous je sais
pas s'il s'agit d'un morceau de moi
on est d'accord donc après cela il
vaudrait peut-être jouer au foot 4 je
sais pas quoi en fait la position n'est
vraiment pas clair les vagues de l'ordi
elle est vraiment ridicule en fait
c'est juste adverse est pas moins en
fait pendant la pratique en tout cas oui
on parle toujours cure de la pratique
makana cas il a l'air d'être dans le dur
hein il réfléchit depuis vraiment
longtemps et
orthez pas pour perdre mais je pense pas
qu'ils posent de vrais problèmes à
radjabov non non
ça se voyait il ya
pas trop à l'épaule
et du thym et tout un ding hockey qui
est ce que c'est dur 2
allée sahel ça avance et vlad chez
firoud hockey what might va faire à
l'eau autour de 8 à 3 pions torah c'est
à 1
je suis sourd l'autre aux plus jeunes
beaufret mahatma six boîtes wakata qu'on
en fait il a fait un truc
parce qu'en fait ça là allez peut-être
pas si facile à défendre
c'est plus facile avec une tour 1 parce
que le cavalier peut pas retourner dans
le joue en fait parce que 8
708 contrôler quoi
et tu veux faire un genre ça
ici après tours et troyes d'accord tu
prends pas
tout rose
to race est ok dommage a par contre
non mais ça commence à écrire en fait
c'est dommage parce que s'ils commencent
par prise prises le pion il est facile à
arrêter et eti les peurs de tourbe et un
ici
encore la fuite quand les deux seuls
parce que ici quand le pion sur trois
est encore
un fragile les points ne veulent pas
prendre sur foot parce que les tours sur
l'échiquier ouais en fait un lieu
important l'important est qu'on la tour
viendra en fait c'est mieux d'avoir les
deux tours sur l'échiquier parce qu'on
est la nôtre en a quatre et vous voyez
qu'elle est beaucoup plus actif que la
tour en elle-même sociaux ouais
donc ça peut être souffrance pour allier
raisin
ça peut être une petite souffrance du
nahd ce que j'appelle une souffrance
eco terre et s'il n'a pas bien joué 2 à
8 pour des raisons que tu viens
d'expliquer
je prends un grand chose à dire sur me
répéter pour les milliers voire je veux
pas le faire parce que tout le monde
sait ce que je dis aux
vases idy bas sur ces insectes de un peu
casse est d'alléger de
thé pour être bien sûr un gros si il y à
une façon de faire ça quelque chose pas
bien dans les finales il le fera beau
mais c'est plus dans les positions
furent au vire à quoi
c'est plus dans les positions techniques
c'est plus sur des petits détails comme
celui là qui peut se trompe au t
il veille au soir c'est son adversaire
dont vous pouvez sur ses cadres parce
que sinon ce qu'il veut faire ça en fait
intermédiaire qu'on mette un terme aux
poursuites qu'il
faut parfois trop et je garde toutes les
possibilités
mais si je remets ma tour en 1 6
vh commence de danse école été cisco et
possède avec les
dts à ce qu'on appelle une fenêtre chien
ça c'est chiant parce que là il faut
qu'il faut absolument tout ça
parce que ça y est tu peut plus offrir
du coup avec le mans
vraiment y réfléchir
fo 6 4 6 4 est il un problème gros
[Musique]
genre ça m'était pas oublier pourquoi
t'as pas fait qu est
ce qu il ya un problème
c' est pas ok tu te ramasses ue-russie
seul ça doit livrer
encore les c4 peut-être bof
méprisé cavalière fille de salaire cool
propre
professionnels way et carole a indiqué
fu le concours sent prêt à l'hérésie
j'espère qu'il va jouer ça
tu peux aussi faire que remanier suite
directe peut-être en fait ok mais c'est
gourmand non mais ça donne la case
justice
ces choses qu'aucun john wood défend
je préfère les décisions tranchante pour
laisser moins d'options à l'adversaire
ouais pour moi on m'a cassé la tête
parce que je sais pas pour chacun de ces
différents mais pour moi mais de
défendre c'est très fatigant répond moi
aussi pour tout le monde je pense parce
que je sais qu à la fin du compte mais
le masai et j'avais réussi que je refais
news sa mort politique ça il a fait un
bond c4 au web sur moi avec l'idée que à
ma montre et on va très vite le voir
comment ces quatre ses forces et ça va
être jouer instantanément
alireza on va le voir là bas il va jouer
à
il va rejouer quasiment tempo ici
d'ailleurs après que les fuites s'y
[Musique]
rapporte plus que m'étonnerait fort
c'est nul tout aussi d'après fritz
retour si
je l'avais vu ça là
ok tu y avait des affiches jouer
trouvent les coups quand même à les
réseaux aujourd'hui fait une partie de
professionnels
bon faut ce 4e volet feat
c'est quand même beaucoup d' oui mais
bon professionnel
parce que nous on est au courant que son
adversaire savent pas quoi faire avec
son fou sur réussit à d'ailleurs vous
vous rappelez qu'il ya cinq ou dix
minutes que ça a été dit qu'il ya un
printemps depuis que les finales étaient
rivés sur l'échiquier le problème de
noir a été que l'exercice était obstruée
par le fou ouais
et donc on rapporte a été affreuse à de
libérer cette case là pour dire qu
il comprend pas l'essentiel de les
finales quoi mais tu as dit qu'ils
n'étaient pas rapporte s'était pas non
plus un bar réputé pour être un groupe
où un joueur de finale il n'est pas
assez
lapasset travailler avec son
domaine qu'est ce qu'on plus
important
bon ça va faire une petite ville
tranquille c'est ce qu'on était venu
chercher aujourd'hui façon il pouvait
pas faire plus 1-0 et a pas un seul
moment dans cette partie
écrire est que un portefeuille voit-on
ibrahimovic a fait
avec sa coupe toujours
le charisme en moins
comme un complot est incomparable
mais ça n'a aucun rapport avec son nom
je vois pas de richard
a été mal à mal cadré
n'ont plus vu que c'est une partie très
importante pour ali reza demain ce
serait bien qu'il se fatigue pas trop
devant l'échiquier aujourd'hui
- il conserve l'énergie et il va pouvoir
cibler le péno
et oui puisque demain c'est penalty pour
ali reza
qu'est ce qu'elle va être important de
cette partie
ciba hikaru en fait il se place vraiment
wim est d'ailleurs il est vrai que c'est
que la dernière ronde comment j'allais
troisième
comment dire le temps coule les ronds de
passe passe il faut quand même moment
donné montrer et pleutre trépasse
après il ya eu deux fois les noirs donc
s'ils tournent à plus 1 et qui lui reste
cinq blancs de noirs à la sortie ça peut
être bien aussi
[Musique]
- ouais ouais ouais ouais
il va faire nul aujourd'hui donc d'oran
trois séries mais voici pourquoi partant
de la première partie du tournoi les
autres ont marqué plus contre ces deux
parce que c'est des web apps oui
oui donc mais quoique il a fait déjà une
nulle autre voie et mouettes une
obligation
donc marquer absolument dans la deuxième
partie oui mais contre des tales ça
devrait quand même passé ouais quand
entraide et elle normalement
10 carnaval se mettre très bien mais
caruana jeu suivant del sûr qui gagne
aujourd'hui il faut arrêter de regarder
les et val-d or die d'ailleurs si rom
mes collègues élitiste quoi oui
l'une des plus grandes faiblesses de
fabrice do sous estime les attaques de
l'adversaire
il n'a rien contre affaiblir son droit
pour dégâts matériels
mais souvent des ressources estime alors
les ressources quoi
de dépôt mais moi j'ai pas de cou en
pêcheur quoi qu'il arrive et quoiqu'il l
évolution de la position de n'est pas
bien il faut dire qu'à moins que le
tabou de la partie et pour la touche sur
ces renvois à la tour sur sedo conquois
c'est
c'est une partie que l'opa les quoi
c'est une très belle partie ça joue sur
toutes les cases de l'échiquier
non c'est une très belle partie
tout cas tout se passe bien pour nous
tiens ça a joué côté
côté famille il a joué fou prend f 5 1
ou principale voie tout autre manière il
faut dire que à un moment donné dans
cette partie il devait prendre sur sa
wii tu pouvais pas laisser son et
tolérer un tel
cheval sur cinq non tu peux pas un
moment donné il lit les fois le prendre
et maintenant c'est intéressant qu'il
est le coup le plus précis coin parce
que le redis d'entourer ses rites neige
peux vous garantir un internement fait
pas de sens
parce qu'on ne voit pas trop de raison
du froid dans ce sac de gens maintenant
et surtout on voit pas de raison de vous
lire elle cède donc a nettement fait
jamais ça
oui possible d'ailleurs tout à 7 les
deux romans peut faire aussi pour les
mêmes raisons
pour la suite je pense pas
donc je prévois alors à autour à 1,8
ou bien doit s' est elle possible
d'apparence un peu plus tôt possible
pour à s'être un peu plus mais logique
ouais
on va retourner chez ali reza ça
réfléchit côté rapporte
est d'ailleurs wheels et les vrais
alireza donc c'est que veux dire par là
one corporal qui ont peut-être
pour la première fois dans la peur dalet
pour la deuxième fois dans la partie et
se sent tout à fait un portail là il va
la tenir simplement pas parce qu'on voit
pas comment
à comprendre comment tu vas perdre ça
après richard qui va forcément jouer
rapidement on n'est qu'au 26e coup il
reste 26 minutes donc là à partir de
maintenant la partie va se ré accélérer
et on devrait vite rentré dans une
position décisive ici quand j décisif
c'est décisif pour une huile un jeu va
les regarder c'est le résultat d'un
maximum en top 16 on voyait donc en fait
qu'est-ce que les échecs charge avec
chaque génération ce qu'ils ont il est
clair qu'ils rapportent kalkuhl calcul
beaucoup mieux qu'ils ont la plupart des
joueurs d'élite 2 il ya 50 ans mais je
peux pas mentionner quelqu'un comme je
peux à pitre gmt grande
tournée miles wanderson woolf de jouer
que les c4 parce que quand les c4 paraît
bizarre une fois tu vois pour se gratter
que les futures
ça paraît un coup bien
collaborateurs avec son adversaire et
non je vais pas jouer pageant de quoi
avant top3 il est vrai plutôt que trois
j'ai même pas considéré parce que j'ai
pas sur ce coup mais est ce que ça me
fait vraiment peur ben
pâton hockey leçons et 2 je suppose
jouer après que les rues si ce programme
autour de cette roue a jouit de fouet 3
et conquois pour l'instant peu de
défauts un diu depuis ces quatre
attaques c6 un stand by comme ça y'a
plus il n'y a pas de tours à cette non
plus donc alors il faut réfléchir
comment on fait alors maintenant
des terrains autour de 8 alors
il voit juste qu'il m'a dit ici stores
baissés 3g si moi je suis déjà je
cassais d'eric roy jouissent vois je
suis ses livres et que c'est notre
manière j'accorde faut y croire
et maintenant 5 avec les des
housses 5
est tombé 5 et décale
hockey quoique
toujours ses six d'abord
à quoique attend dans ce cas
est sain c'est mieux pour les blancs non
quoique
yanzhou pas précieusement ça peut tenir
pour les bois mais pas sûr si tu joues
près sûr parce que parce que le plus on
bouge pas amer et le roi est pas si bien
oui alors que le roi g6 et bien placé au
et mais c'est vraiment logique qui a
valu aussi sur un g6 c'est le truc le
plus logique non naturelle naturelle
mais qu'est ce que j'ai perdu deux
instances
c'est que je regardais se pose après qu
il existe heureusement pas vu roger
10 n'a qu'a pris l'avantagé
dans le secteur des quatre et
six tours f3 tour ses quatre tours 3 se
pose pour cette écriture à rêves de te
recettes décide
donc
tu peux retourner c'est
donc autour de 4 et 6 ans joue dedans
moi deux
d'un bush qui coupa au g37 rémy
9,6 hors cee 4 et les pieds ça c'est sûr
que c'est mieux hi hi hi hou là
un nouveau rameurs peur sont enlevés
cet hymne aux personnes là on est déjà
quasiment finie pour lui et sarre ménaka
en route un
et tu peux retourner la tour sur le sens
que c'est un plus pour essayer de
comprendre qu'est ce qui est le fun le
feu
en fait
d'autre manière peut-être il faut
brouiller le pion c'est horrible on en
oublie trop les cases noires où
on trouve être un peu chez huawei
complexe on va voir ce que ça joue côté
ali reza il ya des coûts chez français
il ya eu cavalli roanne ah oui là je me
roy g8
au coeur raison pour
joost aucun des trois mois il n'a pas
joué moi je suis parce que c'est pas bon
il n'a pas joué parce que la preview
merci c'est tellement logique non donc
je bois de l'eau voilà barrois sinon roi
jouit donc si tu vois moi je suis c'est
bizarre parce que moi tu marques tu
seras obligé de jouer 50 ouais il tu
aurais pu faire un aussi avec le roi en
gysi et sur l'euro 1 avec le roi sûr j'y
serais pas obligé d'aujourd'hui et puis
les mêmes même su fait h5 il est mis en
jeu ici c'est pour repartir en achète
que g8 en fait oui
croatie c'était le coup facile
ils disent le prennent drôle si c'était
fou et 3 f4 f5
oui ok
fgf up 5
bah je sais pas mais ça doit être pour
ça qu'il n'a pas joué en tout cas
et si un jour 5 notre marque
la même chose
non c'est henri iv
et maintenant j'ai pas comme tout à leur
nom ouais
ça a l'air cool quand même ça tu veux
tour d un tour ces deux mois va pas
perdre ça oui il faudra été un petit peu
précis quant à un moment donné non il
faudra être précis comme parce que oui
j'ai un truc à dire
maintenant maintenant avec le bio sur m6
ci-après imaginé autour de 5% précise
les noirs sacrifie les deux tours pour
le foot de quatre noms une tour pour le
autour de 4 est le pion points et 1
arrive quatre pions
sur l'île du roi contre 3 plus encore
ses doigts comme les plus sûrs et si ce
n'était pas évident de prendre ça parce
qu'avec le plongeon réussi c'est très
facile de crier l'opion passait rejoint
f80
ya peut-être une bonne nouvelle
hikaru qui auraient raté quelque chose
après tout on sent qu'il a joué des six
direct aux eagles ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle balade au nickel
sassus côtes américains
ok il veut pousser 6,17 le marlou
hockey bof je bouffe aux faux ceux ci se
tournent autour d'un trou
et puis jojo alors je pensais plein
d'âme au dow de même gagné pour
jaffer c'est que c'est
moi qui ai tour d'entre eux huit dames
ce set
du lancement gagné
jusque là dans beaucoup de tours 2 1
ouais
j'avais pas la réf encore que même si la
dame de foy et c'est un problème ça sans
problème
ouais
et
et un quart one a
pour but 8 ah ok ok je vois il lui
aurait mené sa tour sur b4 pour qu'il ya
plus de 4h
4g pas vieux synthés des moins six
pendant les parties je pense que j'aurai
vu hyper loupe ouais
pendant les parties j'ai rêvé je pense
d'ailleurs
mais j'ai vraiment bien la pause reste
toujours pas claire parce que mr où il
livrait une fois la tour est surbooké tu
ne peux plus dire que l'euro à noir est
faible
ça dft affaibli le roi noir contre sur
damas cinq étapes à tomber 4 à cause de
foot g5 ou oui alors surtout je sens que
je vais jouer pour jouer et maintenant
je veux
pas ce que je peux
et pas tactique hu a pas de tactique en
fait
on mange bien ce coup là ouais
j'ai eu le réflexe trop pleutres
d'autrefois dans cyrus est peut-être le
prince ali reza qui réfléchit maintenant
attention il va pas falloir glissé
on a vu une chose est claire conques tu
peux pas échangé le tour qu'on ne peut
pas attaquer de 2
soit tu veux au procès cinq
soit tu veut libre et en droit si tu
veux libérer tout droit d'abord du
joueur c'est un peu con
dans ce cas là c'est un peu con dans
l'armee laurent g8
ici on fait les mêmes choses moyens avec
les coups qu'on avait 104 4 à 5 4 et
maintenant ça
y'est vincent collet des 4 x 4 et 6
étaient à tour social
l'idée de ses théâtres ses sites web
dont 404 il faudra trouver un autre truc
non mais qu'il puisse faire c'est 5 et
c'est tout un
voyage tesla dors pas je pense qu'il
faudrait être un peu précis je compose
je montrais pour quelles raisons oui
mais bon c'est quand même le coup
c'est quand même le coup
ça crie cas
cette maxime il a fait nul contre
korobov
quelle couleur noire mais c'était là la
grünfeld
colombophile a effacé la partie
normal il ait eu peur quoi
c'est logique en fait je me demande qui
viennent est-ce que de l'école irizar à
va pas voir 14
non c'est on va voir cette finale quand
il aura les noirs mais quand il aura les
blancs je pense que ça va est ce que ces
pinces et intense non non non je pense
que ça va être différent conti jours
avec les blancs
[Musique]
ils disent rose signée dingli rennes
contre duda on recevoir
d'autres
arrêter l'hémorragie
ging avec les noirs qui tient le demi
point il reste plus que trois partis
aujourd'hui et radjabov qui a joué dam
des cinq
peut-être le bon coup
nepeut caruana sa clique et donc nous on
va rester sur surfe irujo
bon il va rouler une position correcte
encore il va pas la perdre
il joue peut-être même encore pour
gagner mais bon c'est bien pour nous
s'il se remet pas dans le tournoi
puisque alireza le foot demain il vaut
mieux qu'ils soient un peu démoralisés
on va dire que c'est plus intéressant
pour nous
d'avoir
un ding un peu
1-1 accapare dont un peu en dessous
on est ce que ali reza s'est vraiment
fait
civile et sur la finale aujourd'hui pas
su ans mais c'est sûr que ses
adversaires sont
s'ils ont l'opportunité après de rentrer
dans une finale c'est sûr qu'ils sont
contents
tu veux montrer le classement c'est
simple il ya 2 2 joueurs en tête c'est
caruana et et nepomniachi qui jouent
ensemble
et deux joueurs distancé
pour le moment hikaru eding
jeu mauvaise nouvelle à vous annoncer
cette finale et
chanteur désagréable exemple 5
pouces à 5 tours 8 autour ce système
pour
tour 6 buts 4 qu elle est de 4 tours de
4e des émeutes rapport au fond des
cratères retour à 5 pour bloquer la
colonne et puis après tout droit de
trois arrêts au caire est assez
désagréable
ouais
ça c'est désagréable en a posé à côté de
ça avec toi va trop vite pris sur
ordinateur
ça doit rester nul non
mais il faudra t'as fait quoi donc
peut-être vaut mieux de jouer passé 5
maintenant au plus tôt
c'est une mauvaise nouvelle
sassine nouvelle
ils disent que n'est pas gaffe et
n'importe quoi c'est pas des gaffes en
fait c'est juste des coups il ya mille
fois en b2
il ya des bons élèves qui se perdent
car vous je pense pas qu'ils la gagnent
ça l'a
en fait c'est l'égalité matériel mais
comme quoi elle veut donc voila ce sens
qu'au
hockey d'abord aller au collège donc
soit les droits doivent joueur ou un fil
de soi sinon quand le sanguin la partie
mais d'apparence les deux doigts votre
nom
à savoir faire nous le cqr
donc ici il paraît qu'il doit jouer cinq
mois avec l'edf 4 kevin est maintenant
peut-être
quatre pour frapper sur alcatel affaibli
par le cou aux cadors n'ont hélas se
doit c'est mieux
mais c'est pas c'est pas réussi c'est
qu'elle ad'ailleurs tour à quatre et six
tours 6
ça valide et 8 laddh oui
voilà
simple et jolie
100 quand l'orage quatre députés après
oui
mais tant qu'il n'y a pas que les
ouvertures qu'il faut regarder
c'est bête parce qu'il tenait
il tenait là nul mais c'est faux est
tellement précis
à ce niveau là
à vous savez en fait
jusqu'à quand c'est pour vous
andré garde en commandes fermes prête
les finales de ce tournoi un petit casse
et pour surtout aussi aux joueurs pour
quelqu'un de plus fort que vous quand
vous vous êtes dans une finale où vous
pouvez pas vraiment gagner
je vous concède être le plus clair
possible dans vos choix c'est moins de
possibilités avant de l'agresser parce
que quand même quand quelqu'un est un
petit peu mieux il est quand même plus
facile pour lui de vous torturer connaît
plus possibilité oui essayez d'eau donc
était très net dans vos choix et coupler
ces extras possibilité quoi parce que
sinon vous allez donc finir un choix ne
fut pas désagréable qui nul certes mais
il faut le faire sur l'échiquier oui
vaut mieux donc un petit coin c'est
lui couper l'herbe sous le pied pourrait
couper l'herbe sous le pied voilà
parce que je trouve souvent chez mes
élèves ils me disent là je veux pas
forcer parce que obama savoir c'est nul
oui c'est new mind your comment will
rock you as tu laisses le truc tu restes
chez toi
tu as plus de chances de faire une
bêtise que son adversaire ouais tu vois
ta ta ta ps qui dit merci je penserai
pour les prochains candidats
bah écoute
que par exemple jeudi et à l'endommager
livre qui à
2006 avant ce que je le répète souvent
en fait comme quoi sagesse que je vous
ai formulé total il la suit on a tous
n'ont pas encore
il faut bien pire danger pas eu dizaine
d'etf ionale pour bien comprendre qu'il
prend des photos possibles d'ailleurs
c'est souvent défaut du nucléaire murac
en effet dominé par carson daly finale
il traîne et rennes après un train comme
ça et me dugas tandis que dès le premier
coup il faut je coup par coup dur qu'à
séka séka séka s'est serré la main
au lieu de traîner parce que il est bien
sûr d'autres mais contre des joueurs
moins voir mes côtés car sans source
europe 1 après c'est pas facile non me
sens trahi
parce que
c'est pas moi c'est d'ailleurs mario ce
qui est à dire pourquoi est ce que il
est si bien dans le final parce que il
essaie d'être précis sur chaque coup 1
il est sûr chapeau il faut montrer à ses
adversaires c'est presque une citation
il veut montrer à ses adversaires qu'il
faut offrir graphe daily finale conquois
égale presque autant que de les
positions compliquées de jeu pour les
siciliens
voilà il faut aussi avoir le physique
pour le faire
tout à fait
tu as bien fait de noter
ça me fait penser à nadal ils disent que
c'est un des seuls joueurs qui mène 40 0
et où qu'ils soient a mené 40-0 il joue
pareil en fait tous les points il joue
pareil ah ouais j'ai jamais compris qu
alors que les autres ou qui est des fois
ils risquent plus si risqué - en fait
lui il en a absolument rien à faire dans
tous les cas ils jouent pour gagner le
point à 100%
ça fait une différence en fait sur un
match
retour des 8 au ppte être bernet corps
il réfléchit bien sûr à la case t4 il a
vu que ce 5 plutôt non donc
elle essaie de passer par un autre moyen
oui papa être parce que d'autres maniére
âge s'accroît chez trois jeux 6 et pas
au goût de tout le monde quoi
mais est est ce que le ménage quelque
chose est ce que quand il ya des
catastrophes menace aux magyars f4 c'est
quand même le coup franc vite joué
[Musique]
les tours
par contre c'était hyper cool mais c'est
vrai au lieu de 3 2 3 qui viendront à 2
2 avec les détours entorse à
ses patrons tour c'est ici des plus tôt
moi j'ai pensé à tout ce remue la table
plutôt d'un échec
oui c'est vrai
et surtout rachat c'est si simple course
et cette rage de
romain est le plus beau jeu 3 s'est
défendue par la tour sûr je serai
ok jeu 6
1 jusque là tout va tout droit
ça pue pour les noirs ça non c'est pour
bientôt et puis comme ça ça pue bien sûr
qu'ils aient au moins palandri de
analyser ça parce que
mais ça il peut se faire piéger fierro
déjà roi des deux c'est pas facile ouais
à quoi que sur quatre sur quatre qu
est-ce qu encore
il peut juste rien ferreux enfin 5 au
prochain ouais je vais dire ok une fois
f5 je vais le faire connaître il a joué
ff4 la gentille 500 qui est des cats au
web vous prend mais c'est pas pareil
je veux dire c'est pas pareil parce que
maintenant les structures dotées pions
904 n'est plus aussi souple des
oiseaux comme à voir ou à 7
les quatre
bref si ce
n'était quand même pas loin de défaites
bourbourg tour a
lancé
sa plus grave en fait voilà jeté à terre
tout autre
en fait c'est ce qu'il ait pas deux
doigts d'être foutu chioggia non pour
foutyou moi j'ai pas loin de perdre là
quand même
aïe c'est terrible c'est pas une bonne
partie d'alireza ça se présentait bien
ils disent que raj a gaffé durement
aie aie a rien qui va bien non radja ça
va
ça dit n'importe quoi dans le tchat
caruana ça vaille à thoune qui dit
n'importe quoi en fait
hilton d éval qui n'existe pas
dans la position et des gueux en fait
mes lordi en fait il un cri d'un h5 f5
et les quatre fous des quatre
tours prend des quatre tours condé 4
prend dé 4,3 des 3c 5
ouais ok c'est malin ça regarde
en fait l'idée c'est que ce retour c4 je
vais tour c63 ici et y menace jamais de
prendre ce cas le pion dépasser hockey
le plus important que le biome sur cinq
fois sur 29 et maintenant quand tu
rentres dans la 4 contre 3 nuls facile
donc ça c'est sûr que c'est nul donc en
fait ça qu'il faut trouver h5 f5 et des
quatre fous des quatre tours des quatre
il va prendre tu prends hockey dans ces
cas là bref c'est un cadeau
ok mais si pas f5 qui fait quoi j'ai
jojo un truc comme moi je craque en
trois sets
ok il a fait carélie des cats direct
c'était sûr
c'était sûr en fait
cette fois ci pour le 'dow' graff ou un
truc dans la zone finalement fait il a
fait roi g8 et où ses pas pour h5
justice et trompait globalement en fait
ça va être dur de gagner les candidats
mais je sais que ça m'avait à quoi ça me
ressemble c'est comme j'ai un nouveau
élèves et tout de suite oui ses parents
me disaient parfois six mois entre mois
une analyse de grichka votre voix une
analyse que je suis moins bien s'y
attend est-ce que tu connais par exemple
comment en fioul dans les finales de
tours contre les prêts à jouer non
montrez-moi une analyse de griche
mépriser tout cas pas ce que chacun
pense que il est une recette magique aux
échecs tu vas prendre le pas une mission
comprennent bowling une ligne piège qui
va battre avec laquelle tu vas battre
tout le monde que voilà en gros ils
veulent gagner des parties grâce à moi
m'a pas grâce à leur niveau culturel et
moi un échange dit écoutez
de respirer une ligne devrait choquer
travaille d'abord les finales quoi je
pourrais les calculs etc ici je pense
que donc bâtir usa n'a pas travaillé les
finales et aux grands avant ce tournoi
c'est faible parce qu'il commençait bien
trop visible pour tout le monde au
courant
ça sent pas bon
ok un noir si son patron national de
dawson
notorious
des sources du losc quoique bien sûr il
a beaucoup fait
non mais ce qui fait peur c'est pas ça
c'est au cours de ses trois derniers
trous pour
pour
fait mal au coeur ouais
ouais
que les pires cours de l'effet noël et
les photos du sud est ajouté mme
pauvreté qui réfléchit pas en fait oui
c'est inquiétant quand même
bon après c'est pas grave s'ils gagnent
pas cette année il gagnera dans deux ans
mais à
quoi que oui avec
cette technique là où il se demande
mme après la sq est bête en plus c'est
qu'il avait très bien fruits pendant un
long moment
puis il a commencé à faire son truc avec
fougue et 4 qui était un peu trop fort
s'en est d'ailleurs sans aucune raison
pourquoi tout fort ce site est pas moins
bien
vos voisines jousse -9 parce que dans
les faits mais très souvent il est vrai
vous pouvez pas gagner vous pouvez pas
rien faire moins pour autant des
jeux page 104 comme je montrais mais
c'est pas que vous jouez sakuma les
siciliens avec l'hérault composée
ou
will voie ferrée
je dis d'ailleurs tu te rappeler hier
jeudi que rapport à beaucoup amélioré
ses finales avec ceux
là il ya en fait il n'a pas si mal joué
la finale rap rapporte gilles a mal joué
l'ouverture
en oies
c'est fini pour les biens non pas du
tout s'il voit perdre et c'est à cause
d'ailleurs encore une très longue route
pour perdre ça il peut revenir mais bon
c'est moins 11 ans et pas moins de nom
ce moment soit une obligation de gagner
rapidement une partie oui oui il est
vrai que quand on a perdu nos compteurs
communicants 2010 est très très content
de gagner tout de suite
très très content important de gagner
contre il y en a déjà quand vous ça vous
savez quand vous savez en avant ce qu'il
vous faut marquer au moins +37
dépressifs des témoins en afrique il
faut
marquer marquer
c'est pas encore perdu vaut mieux qui la
sauve aujourd'hui
ce que l'un des deux en fait on peut pas
juste temporisé genre h5 maintenant ou h
6 h 5
et à tour bob à 4 qui est possiblement
c'est vrai que nature à rendre
une fois tu bouges bouche tempo une fois
qu'ils viennent à 5 qu'est ce que je
vais dire si tours bob à 4 là après toi
peut-être j'ai plus autant pour d'autres
c'est si
le retour des quatre têtes je prends et
je réagis en h1 je joue à 4 15
h 4
et je veux h3 tourache en eau sur ja je
veux tout rachat je vais pas te laisser
possibilité de jouer tout rachat h4 est
plus tours 2-3 mais bon même ça
ait de tels coûts de telles positions
c'est très dur de jouer juste comme ça
il faut calculer quoi
mais bon ça ça fait peur
possible quoi
que les blancs qui n'ont cessé que les
besoins depuis très très longtemps
depuis que les raisins joue au poker
depuis calais reza a décidé de
donner en cadeau à son adversaire qui
ont un mois depuis quatre ans joue que
comporte le résultat est fabiano n'est
pas sa fille nue 1 c'est signé
fabien n'est pas nul nul way home c'est
une tragédie quoi lebid a fait la diff
l'add on commence à
big deal pour
agréable mais la même avec l'orangé
s'ils sont d'accord c'était probablement
nulle part fouquet new look miu le
maillot de lille x mio kwh
mais en général avec le bio sur m6
comment lier des tarifs même de mettre
le papy sorif jouer mais il est bien
aussi jamais les maths qua non mais
c'est bizarre en partie soit en effet
roi g60 qu'elle fait là ok il faut qu'on
soit bon il le faut nous ferons comme ça
quand on se fout bien de rejouer 8e
complexe
alors au
problème quoi droits des deux n'avait
pas je pense ouais
typique très typique pour les joueurs
dynamiques dans les faits mal de ratés
en course 1 poule parce qu ils ont
toujours les tendances de calgary néron
à détroit et ouais
la position de l'air de rien si il perd
cela écrivons alireza une lettre ouverte
où
andré j seront une vidéo avec les web et
de notre communauté
qui travaillent les finales
donc des îles de revers sur plusieurs
pages et sur chaque page travail les
jeunes à travers les fenêtres travail
les fenêtres travers les fenêtres à
voile fnl
et si tu fais des trois-tours c3 sa
rente hors des trois
pour des trois-rois prendre h un om et
maintenant
e
totalement pardon
on pas croire il faut calculer quoi ok
images montrent toujours au
chat
non non non je peux être qui tourne à 12
tours 7 de rage 2 go 4
dont je dois je suppose tube ou du rejet
3 est toujours roi ce cadre et là on ne
peut pas dire comme ça vraiment calculer
quoi peut-être mieux que 7e roi est
mauvais mais pour gien voit
passer par une frange ici c'est sûr que
c'est tellement tellement mieux en fait
peut-être ce nul
[Musique]
peut-être aussi que j'ai moi je veux
avec les bons
par garde fait l'ordi
mais si vous voulez comme hans op l'a
assez bien joué l'évolution notons que
l'évolution
ami l'a fait tour en direct sa paire
instant tu
sais ce qu'on a regardé tout à l'heure
sont cons ces six tours h un tour c'est
cet ouvrage de roide et 3g 6 et on n'a
même pas voulu regarder tellement c'est
dégueu
qu'est ce qu'il a mal joué en fait la
finale
c'est trop la whey maintenant à so foot
you puisque
[Musique]
ouais ça c'est plutôt le scat que trois
et demi
bon maintenant
ce que le dieu le protège quoi
s'en sort avec des prothèses enfants
maintenant c'est foutu pour les
premières fois
ouais mais la finale il a il a mal il a
mal maîtrisé un
hoquet le crime et le châtiment
donc
on dit je comprends pourquoi ma miss
jolie fille route déjà
[Rires]
ouais ce serait un massacre en fait
contre magee souhaite ya même pas de
match bah si tu perdes et elle fait mal
comme ça
ok maintenant
de toute manière elle va faire
contempler les techniques de richard et
charia je proposais un point de façon de
jouer ça
ok à prendre les choses comme elles sont
à ses enfants at il énoncé
doit par exemple aussi très fausse à
tout moment vous dis qu'est-ce que je
connais c'est grave moi je ferais mais
j'aurais sûrement fait ça et je serai
[ __ ] je comprends pourquoi j'ai arrêté
les échecs parce que quand il fait des
trucs
pourquoi jouer en fait
il faudra vite réagir demain
ouais
alors
les amis dans les finales avec les
opinions sur m6 essayez de ne pas mettre
votre roi sur le huitième pour qu'il ya
quand même moins de dôme at elle énoncé
terrible surtout sans aucune idée claire
sinon d'ailleurs avec l'orangé six
semaines un coup comme tour g8 peut
beaucoup mieux défendre ouais mais tu as
fait à tanger de tanger 3 après sinon si
c'est une fille mal égal c'est pas la
peine de les rendre
chacun chaque joueur est content de
jouer
avec sécurité
à part ça
il faut jamais oublier qui on joue pas
les finales comme un joli mais le milieu
du show c'est tout à fait un auteur
dommage toutefois si un changement de
rythme
ouais ce que veut dire ce qu'ils ont si
après le milieu du jour vous rentrez
dans le final souvent ce qu'il faut
faire il faut souffler et or ont évolué
les choses parce que les mauvaises
pièces dans cooper devenir bon et du
coup le vice versa et puis donc pas mal
de choses
la logique de les parties peuvent être
différentes et tu pense qu'il va réussir
à régler ce problème des finales où il a
pour toute sa carrière comme garde-fou
que cannes est ce que les premières fois
que je te dis que cela grands problèmes
longtemps tu m'as dit c'est un énorme
problème mais j'ai pas l'impression
qu'ils aient travaillé ce jour mais sur
ce à quoi on s'est pas privé qu'il a
vraiment pas de talent pur non
parce que pour la présence juste bien
trop tu vois il va jamais devenir con
car cette demi finale mais ils purent
voir le niveau correct ça se travaille
non non c 'est pas qu'une antoniou ton
quoi tu
fais là quand même des années pour le
résoudre gamme dynamics man
oui mais à cet âge là ni cap ovnis
kasparov ne peut pas les techniques dans
les faits n'est pas aussi mauvaise que
ça
c'est quoi les pires parmi les joueurs
de ce niveau là je veux dire kasparov à
sa tâche il était déjà 2e au monde oui
mais
non sa technique n'était pas comme ça
quand même non jammet croit
c'est pas rassurant ce que tu nous dis
mais fisher c'était pas terrible en en
finale
c'était pas si mauvais mais parce que
les premiers candidats il avait 16 ans
fischer
il avait deux ans maintenant à vrai dire
je commets pas à temps à tan tan tan tan
l'ordi peut-être gaffe aux 4 c'est
bizarre comme coûts et les repas offerts
par exemple ont
fait aux 2,7 hors jeu trois roues à t4
par exemple et puis d'options pathway de
pantalons ou et il veut te reprends
retour j'ai sept rois f8 et aussi ce nom
mais là-dessus à tour trois échecs et on
prend aussi je voulais faire maths en
fait tu
attends attends quand on prend g3 de
façon il va faire il a plus de 2 minutes
1 alireza pour pour trois coups c'est
qu'il est en train de faire un truc pas
très pro rapporte on attend c'est de
jouer vite sur le times note de l'autre
quand est gagnant ok il est urgent et
roidot s'est trouvé six mois bien
entourage
7,3 au f4 sur le court 1 g 8 ha ok
ok ok ok ok joe danger c'est 3 à 8 ans
j'ai six
sur le cou de taureau crise
quoique seul coup un peu d'auteurs
semaine
à écouter
à l'aîné ce gros encore deux courts ce
que rapporte il n'a pas des bons airs et
là il a fait au moins 4 on va dire que
c'est pas le coup en fait qui m'a choqué
c'est jouer aussi vite avec un quart
d'heure le pot teneur oui il a pas de
neige mais je veux dire c'est un peu ça
peut sauver ça le fait qu'il ait pas pu
sauver ouais parce que la rue est futile
car rien que par le maire du type ouais
il est obligé droit 8la alireza roi et
fille de pardon
que à change pas grand-chose en vrai il
faut jouer un coup il a fait roi h suite
ça change pas grand chose tout racheter
trois rois g8 il va récupérer
ok ils récupèrent les 50 minutes ali
reza
i la récup 50 minutes
à
ouais est ce que c'est vraiment perdant
vraiment dans ce cas là en fait c'est un
peu tu peux trouver les coups juste
parce que tu as plus le choix pour 1-0
devant l'ordi oui ces perdants
mais [ __ ] darel faudra être un peu
plus précis qu à voir
au fond hockey comme quoi ils peuvent
maintenant
nouveau 3 entendu est-ce que j'ai pas
des trois
îles réa tourache rita lafond qui vient
des trois rois je dois tout autour des
chaussettes j'ai compris
mes fans y regarder quand même ouais
donc trois tours troyes
s'est vite
c'est pas évident non rockets il a de
chance parce que c'est hamdi prêts à les
ordinateurs et quand c'est dur on a quoi
comme il est vrai bien sûr c'est dur de
jouer quand même pour le noir avec eux
peut-elle donc sur le septième inquiet
mais tombe et
3a et maintenant il ya une scission que
tu peux pas et tous rêvent 7 et tombeur
écoutait les turbines dont pas 09 non
c'était dur bien d'autres nations qui
avait été scié c'est presque plus que la
tour des cinq tours f7 au caire g8
pas évident de comprendre
ce que même en sachant que ces gagnants
à moins peut-être julio d'autoroute
cette eau qui voici tour bobo est
quelque part j'ai huit tours à cet
opus excuse avoir plutôt à doha à
chaussettes
et peut-être terme et m'a alors 6 pouces
un état de droit c'est ça non t'as pas 3
je veux gagner donc de 5 à 10
bref ça tu es
ici je vais faire un tour eu six
taureaux xive
où je bouffe
suite au
hockey mais par hasard tu peux trouver
avec les noirs non bien sûr comment dire
maintenant il faut réfléchir aux bois
tandis qu avant c'était possible il faut
gagner avec l'élément non mais ce que
j'ai ressenti ont vu ces différences
éclats avec les noirs c'est que des
coûts force et tu peux plus se tromper
qu'il je pense que le plus simple
peut-être montrons le plus simple je
sais pas si je me trompe il ya deux
trois ou quatre c'était du joueur ou un
peu d'intérêt chez couach lui trois de
ses droits
peut-être
oui ici roux échec
watch reed du rejet de cette
donc je trouve wasquehal
et je suppose tour de cette tour de 7
avec cependant roulage je pense que je
gagne clairement assez facilement je
pense
enfin mais oui il avait encore 15
minutes et ici il est hyper v joueurs
cadres
ça peut sauver
ok
pour nicole du final pour un
une bouderie les courbes et les
cliniques psychologique sur un noir
précis figues en suisse qu'il co pas
pour l'autre
et peut-être qu'il a pensé que ça ça
gagne et facile
3 la non mais gérard elle joue un thème
pour comme ça tu peux penser de la merde
sa chemise et des races et des guenons
non mais
oui elle est bien à la haye les vendre
les gonades hors dotation maison
et perturbe firo avec une chemise aussi
moche
et c'est non mais en fait c'est pas la
faute de rapporte qu'on critique loin de
là parce que c'est dur ce qu'ils font
mais c'est le fait d'avoir le roi 4
tempo quant à 15 minutes ouais ça c'est
spécial il est resté que trois coiffeurs
bahougne en plus ce qu'est c'était après
ses échecs je viens de voir les
pressions gagnante curieux quelques
coups et voisinage ou soirées chics quoi
et encore une petite chance et tous les
autres ont fait nul 1 n'ont pas tous les
autres il y en a car
tu sais que
ça peut gagner pour n'a qu'à aller coûte
les warmoes réussissent tout chaud
et
ça c'est tellement dur les échecs comme
je
parlais warm up boys c'est vrai que
c'est assez terrible
[Musique]
et voir les voir mark burns
c'est quelque chose de voir mes repères
quand même il l'a préparée quoi [ __ ]
tout raciste geagea je te re 4,5
françois et elle a repris quelque chose
comme
quoi
plutôt ternes torres 6 jaj tour
à tour ses cinq aussi d'ailleurs
je comprends pas les vals en fait
à tours 7 un col de jeu 4
3 et 6 turbo cinq courses 2
mais on peut pas calé en ag du coup
comme ça on prendra b5 sur et chaque
équipe peut pas prendre de f non ma
fille tu as tout raciste jajpur ce sens
qui a voué à tour des six
parce que s'il faut ensuite j'ai collé
le deuil a pas d'euphorie club on va
voir il ajoute en prend aussi sa va
cliquer tempo parce que là il ya 50
secondes pour timour geagea storch 5
ouais je prévois leur décision
- avis qu elles au fond d'un telle
position il ya toujours des chances de
se sauver parce que les positions se
joue sur les deux côtés oui et donc le
faut au moins avec une pièce avec avic
actifs immatériels lofo peut se servir
et d'être très très efficace car ou qui
amincit sauvons le thème de tels faits
n'a la fed
est la plus de 20 secondes
mais bravo icaro ainsi réussi à gagner
quel joueur quand même c'est hikaru
turc actuel
c'est le coup qu'on avait nous
de base à tour décisif aux 8,6
au
tour 6 et si tout réussi sera aussi sur
f5 avec les dérange cadets à coller sur
française
autour des systèmes sert exactement le
genre des cookies aux qui sont libres et
par celui qui joue pas souvent
est-ce que ça arrive que deux joueurs
oublient leurs points de vue we are more
oui oui et d'ailleurs ça arrive à tout
le monde mais rarement
tour de suisse où est bien sûr c'est le
coût très facile à faire par contre il
va le faire si un fourreau 6,8 au niveau
5 tours h4 comme sénoufo ce joueur c'est
ce qu'il va faire ouais c'est jouable
encore tour de force ou non mais t'es
obligé il faut quand même en a et il ya
sûrement tour de huit
et six fours possède maintenant
un regard de
8,1 sur d'euros à six et à coller 5 oui
mais ça y tient on y voit instantanément
surtout qu'il a récupéré une heure
regarde il a vérifié
bien jouer hikaru quand même ok écoute
bien jouer radjabov aujourd'hui à
commencer ce qui était bien prévisible
il a bien commencé et ce qui le début je
suppose
malheureusement firoud que faire les
ventes sur
la photo ct ok mais page c'est sûr qu'il
va gagner
sur scène
pour très peu de temps on va retourner
voir
le prince
le prince de bel air
quel dommage pour ali reza quand même
mais bon il ya encore une chance
c'est repos demain ou lundi c'est tous
les to les sages ou trois jours et ça se
repose
maintenant il car où il a vraiment bien
joué aujourd'hui
a réussi à mettre la pression assez
longtemps sur radjabov qui a craqué
firoud va perdre rien n'est moins sûr 1
allez un petit cadeau de richard
très bien quand amos fasse exprès 20 pas
spécialement parce qu ali reza il a fait
nul à la première contre lui il peut
complètement imposé donner des punto
blanc
et gare aux incroyables impressionnant
c'est le joueur que j'arrive vraiment
jamais à comprendre il me surprendra
toujours
sur ce tournoi il a assez impressionnant
pour le moment
tout cas y réfléchit maintenant
rapportent
ils avaient une face comme ça aux grands
prix contre maxime où il avait très mal
jouer quelques coups et il avait réussi
à re bien joué après
on va voir l'attenté va être longue
la l'attend pour le prochain coup va
être très longue
je préfère vous prévenir
on peut attendre encore une demi-heure
sur ce coup quand vlad reviendra gerra
et j'irai manger un
un petit quelque chose
on a fait un côté français
j'ai un peu de charcuterie en plus
mais voilà c'est vraiment dur
puis les vagues nordistes je peux les
gagner facilement et non parce que les
vals en fait ça veut pas dire le nombre
de coups qui gagne et le problème dans
ces finales là c'est qu'il faut être
précis et que tu sais jamais
ce qu'ils gagnent et ce qu'ils gagnent
pas
c'est jamais évident en fait
la position rabat en gros on voit le roi
g8 est très mal et de tours sont fortes
les pions passer son avance et
il ya des réseaux de maths mais les
noirs peuvent être essayés de d'envoyer
leurs pions des mais cela dit c'est pas
si simple parce qu'on aura besoin de la
tour en 3 pour pour stopper le pion à
eux donc en gros on va on va galérer
envoyé le pion des
c'est complètement foutu mais c'est pas
assez pas ce qui va pas à 100% du temps
trouver les bons coups
le niveau 2
de jeu d'ali reza a laissé
et ai été un peu faible aujourd'hui
dans la finale - moins bon qu'hier
la difficulté des finales par rapport au
milieu d'eux je sais qu'en finale la
différence entre le meilleur coût et le
deuxième meilleur coût et est importante
c'est ce qui rend c'est ce qui rend les
finales difficile c'est pour ça que si
même si c'est plus 10 en fait il peut y
avoir un coût qui donne plus 10 et les
autres coûts qui donne égalité
ça qui est pas évident
c'est ça qui est pas évident
c'est toute la difficulté
richard il était vraiment stressé on va
espérer qu'ils sont un peu fatigués qui
perdre sa lucidité
qui rebute j'allais manger un petit truc
plane je laisse deux minutes d'accord
écoutez mes amis
ça deviendra un petit peu en hauteur
triste habitude que au cinquième heure
du jour
et un très
compliqué
aujourd'hui beaucoup plus compliqué que
hier d'air
aux questions vers créateur c'est foutu
pour les noirs mais est ce que c'est si
foutyou humainement parlant
je sais pas
d'ailleurs juste pour à noter qu'il n'y
a pas des moyens si simple que ça comme
à
tours je sais tu vas vite pour
laisser passer ce que je veux dire il
n'y a pas de moyens si simple que ça
contours de cette posture après tour de
cette tour de cette juste tourbe droit
et les noirs vous enfin nul
donc
il faut quand même
bien trouver
les moyennes beaucoup plus technique
donc on commence à leur paroisse f4
sûrement donc tours troyes est obligé
maintenant alors on m'a dit dis
boukhater avant je suppose
donnez moi juste un petit enfant s'il
vous plaît pour que
je mette ses positions et ses
rêves cratère 3
comme ma part je vois pas tellement
facile en fait pour l'heure du tout
allait ressembler pour moi non plus ce
qui est bien sûr rend optimiste malgré
malgré tout
sur tours je sais 3 suite je pense que
rouaf 8 rue et fit le même
avant ce sont les coups plus ou moins de
la même qualité en fait les deux cas
quand même il faut trouver au brand
comment passer plus tard
souvent dans des délais final c'est une
question aussi des exemples souvent je
sais pas si c'est ici le cas
c'est tellement stressée que j'arrive
pas de calcul est proprement peut-être
vous pouvez nous faire rire que moi
d'air
à tout moment rapport propose n'est
sûrement pas
d'ailleurs qu'est ce que dit sa langue
corporelle non elle ne dit rien du tout
il s'enquiert
ce n'est pas perdue ou encore ses
chances de gagner par contre je ne vois
pas de chemin courir comme au adhère
donc je vais pas vous sortir les lignes
d'ortie qui dure
j'ai pas quand secours parce que je sais
pas à quoi ça sert
est-ce que avril avec nous que tel où il
voit plus couverts mois que
que les autres
ah
oui en plus aux bouffons et bien sûr le
pion sur je suis bien sûr
déjà je sais pas vous voulez prendre
avec qui le tour maintenant vous voulez
apprendre ça avec le pion
avec le roi avec le dos à cette eau est
fit tour g6
ok je joue autour de 8 alors
et maintenant quoi d'interdire je sens
coûts et
dans ces cas là les noirs donc bouge la
tour sur deux villes maintenant jouer 2
3 une fois le tour n'est pas un air sur
trois et je vois toujours pas de façon
quoi sinon un but au bout fois ici avec
l'auteur tour
je sais
la fuite tour j 6 sur 8 encore durer six
à huit
tours h5
et quelque chose quelque chose comme
touristes et maintenant il ya plus de
demande et je pense que ok même si ça
reste dur à défendre
ça me ressemble plus à un nul que une
autre chose
bath qui ont écouté ce qui est une très
bonne nouvelle update 1
si moi je vois rien
c'est pas exemplaire mais veut dire
quelque chose
il repère prix leur dis oui je le sais
ce que j'ai dit je le sais
mais comment
à voir absolument penser le contour joue
bien belle
et tout ça grâce à cette connerie de
durmand quand il a joué aux quatre au
38e coup tandis qu il avait des moyens
beaucoup plus simple
il devait regrouper quelque chose de
basique en fait je sais pas quoi
exactement
braderie de la pose de
je ne sais pas ce qu'ils bord de
la pause final de la partie du corps
vous savez je suis pour les premières
voix
dans une situation de qui viennent et je
sais pas comment mettre ses positions
excusez-moi pas d'expérience
donc j'attends mon collègue pour qu'y
aurait il une proposition de l'aei est
ce que ce
grand que plus donc pour les noirs ou
c'est curieux c'est que le leur dire
et en plus j'ai peur de
l'eau faire une connerie et détruire le
système
ma plus grande peur en fait donc je
touche bon pas trop au mieux
ah oui qu'est-ce que ça se comprend à
killeen est ce que l'un des spectateurs
nous alimenter de jauger leur position
finale du k o ouanna il est dit que
c'était plus de bruit où il accordait
new
way certes on une grosse turbine c'est
très compliqué à et les répéter le coach
rien
c'est juste compliqué
où bodo ok ils menacent alors pour
fouiller et bouffer sur eux c'est ça
il faudra analyser vlad d'accord mais on
ne peut pas dire un
ça fait du bien de manger je dois dire
surtout que j'avais du bon j'ai fini le
jambon au romarin
il va pas être bien en v'là d'
gens m'ont romain quand on y songe
effets extraordinaires
alors il pose une question bon à
laquelle on avait déjà répondu il ya une
demi-heure
il va jouer richard a
il a fait froid f4
de retrouver à tempo c'est le seul coup
j'arrive première fois j'ai fini genre
nombreux ben ouais mais bon il était bon
jambon romain os il ya le bide de retour
ça fait plaisir vlad que même même la
partie finie le bide reste
le retour de la bible du donneur d'ordre
militaire
ça fait plaisir
en fait il est parti bouffer comme moi
il est revenu
déjà le bit en fait assez peut-être
radja en fait le bide ah
parce que normalement les joueurs ont
plus le droit de revenir on n'avait pas
calculé sa balade
on vont le bide c'est peut-être même pas
d'où tu as et peut-être haja a donc il
ya 4 à 3 38 3pts de risques
mais ça peut non et dites moi s'il te
plaît le monde
est venu du monde vide c'est pas parce
qu'on appelle quand quelque chose marche
pas on dit que saab idée
ok je trouverais avec lourties bien sûr
qu'est ce qu'il ya de plus simple
wave 4 tours 3 donc tous âges à sept
rois suite et tout g27
et maintenant tu es prêt de pousser les
pions peu
et touré fuite
rush 5
et humaines asmat d'orage cette tour
et si je fais j'ai cinq échecs
moi je suppose 60 bien sûr
de f3
[Musique]
f4 rouge 5